So, da bin ich. Eine Runde drei Minuten Headbangen, dann geht der Stream los.
So, erstmal checken, bis Twitch richtig mitgekriegt hat,
was der Stream alles. By the way, wer kennt das Game noch vom Soundtrack?
Ziemlich alt schon.
Aber, aber auch ziemlich bekannt.
Das ist der Black Ops 1 Zombie Soundtrack, falls sich noch irgendjemand daran erinnert.
Steiner, der lange schwindet's ab.
Das ist keine TOS Musik.
Das ist Black Ops 1
Zombies Soundtrack.
Black Ops 1 ist meiner Meinung nach das Beste,
was sie rausgebracht haben.
Vielleicht Black Ops 2 noch.
Nein.
Wie lange läuft die Beta noch?
Wir können doch einfach gucken, du musst nicht nachgucken. Ich kann xD... xDfiant...
Beta.
Beta Ende bereits, morgen gibt es... okay.
Die ist vorbei, lol.
Moment, Moment, noch mal, noch...
Noch, noch mal muss nicht.
So, jetzt machen wir wieder ein bisschen was entspannteres an.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Epic
Collection.
Wir machen jetzt Kontrastprogramm, komm hier, sowas da.
Wup, wup, wup.
Bisschen Entspannung, wup, wup, wup.
Ist aus, ne? Hab ich auch grad gesehen.
Deadge.
Ist vorbei.
Ja, mein, das Game kommt ja auch irgendwann mal raus.
Vielleicht gibt's ja noch ne Beta, ich weiß nicht, wann ist denn...
x...
Release...
Date?
Magst du alles trinken? Ich hab gerade.
Sommer 2023.
Moment.
Ist doch jetzt.
Na, wobei, ich glaub offiziell fängt Sommer im...
Juli oder so an.
Ende Juli irgendwann.
Wann ist offizieller Sommeranfang?
Ja, 21. Juni.
Juni?
Also war jetzt schon Sommeranfang gerade?
Vor ner Woche?
Dann war das schon.
Dann war schon Sommeranfang, okay.
Ich dachte mittlerweile,
dass CS2 eigentlich sogar schon
ne Public Beta ist.
Oder irgendwie sowieso was hat.
Aber anscheinend nicht.
Aber ich verfolge das auch nicht so richtig.
Dachte das...
Ich dachte, das ist eigentlich schon durch.
Was meint ihr, was zuerst kommt?
Ein weiteres gutes Battlefield
oder Half-Life 3?
Schwer zu sagen, oder?
Bisschen laut.
Also...
Also ich tippe...
Ich tippe ja tatsächlich drauf,
dass...
dass bevor wieder
ein richtig gutes Battlefield kommt,
Half-Life 3 kommt.
Und wenn es nicht Half-Life 3 ist,
in Half-Life 3 Form,
weil man könnte ja quasi sagen,
dass das VR Half-Life
ja quasi so ne Art Half-Life 3 war.
Auch wenn es ohne Gordon Freeman war,
wobei das nicht ganz stimmt.
Ein paar Sekunden
zum Schluss gibt's ja
Gordon Freeman, aber ansonsten.
Wie fandest du Half-Life VR?
Ich hab's nicht gespielt.
Ich hab kein VR-Headset.
Ich hab keine VR-Brille.
Und ich will mir auch für ein Game,
was mich da richtig interessiert.
Ich mein, es gibt ein paar Games,
aber eigentlich nur ein Game,
was mich richtig interessiert,
will ich mir auch keins kaufen.
Das einzige Game, was mich richtig interessiert,
ist Half-Life.
Vielleicht, was vielleicht auch nicht
gar nicht so übel sein soll,
ist das VR Resident Evil.
Aber ansonsten, ne.
Gibt's nicht auf Ebay,
was zu kaufen?
Auch wenn man es offiziell nicht darf.
Okay.
Ja, aber wie gesagt,
dafür alleine kauf ich mir kein Headset.
Vielleicht,
vielleicht, wenn's mal irgendwie noch
zwei, drei Games gibt, auf die ich richtig scharf bin.
Aber der VR-Hype
ist ja auch so ein bisschen ausgeblieben.
Ja, also.
Ähm.
Vor ein paar Jahren, so mit
Oculus und allem,
wurde ja das Zeitalter
der Virtual Reality heraufbeschworen.
Heißt nicht, dass es so gut
wie keine Games, also.
Also ne, es heißt nicht, dass es nicht gute Games gibt,
aber es gibt so gut wie keine Games.
Also nicht so, wie man sich das damals
vorgestellt hat.
Ja. VR kommt noch.
Ich weiß nicht. Ihr habt das vielleicht nicht mitgekriegt,
aber es gab schon mal,
so in den 90ern,
gab es schon mal so einen VR-Trend.
Und das war halt damals auch
Shit.
Und die Technik war noch deutlich schlechter.
Mittlerweile ist das ja ganz okay, aber so
wirklich, ja so wirklich
überzeugt's die Leute halt nicht. Und anscheinend
reicht die Kreativität der Entwickler nicht aus.
Und die Verbreitung
der Hardware auch jetzt
nicht da irgendwie jetzt Millionenzeller
rauszuhauen, ja.
Das könnte ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen, wobei
das noch ein bisschen dauern wird.
Die erste Generation richtet
sich ja erstmal hauptsächlich an Entwickler.
An dem Preis sieht und
dass halt noch nichts wirklich dafür da ist.
Wobei ich
nicht so sehr glaube,
dass das irgendwie
die VR-Nutzung
für Games jetzt so weit voranbringt,
das Apple-Ding.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen,
es geht ja eher in Richtung Augmented Reality.
Das kann
man sich schon irgendwie ausmalen,
dass das mit der Apple-Brille
in den nächsten Jahren vielleicht
ein bisschen besser gehen wird. Das steht und fällt nicht so sehr
nur mit der Hardware,
sondern auch wie kreativ die Entwickler sind.
Und nicht nur die Apple-Entwickler,
sondern die gesamte Welt an Entwicklern.
Wie kreativ die sind, sich dafür
Anwendungszwecke auszudenken,
die die Leute eben wirklich abholt und
überzeugt.
Wenn es so nice to have ist,
so ein bisschen in Form von
Fitness-Uhren
oder sowas.
Ja.
Und VR ist sicherlich
noch ein bisschen mehr Nische wie
Fitness-Tracker
und Uhren.
Es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass unbedingt alles
immer wahnsinnig erfolgreich ist,
nur weil es von Apple ist.
Besser als
bei Microsoft. Bei Microsoft war es
ja schon so, dass die teilweise richtig
Dampf gemacht haben, was neue Technologien angeht
und das dann vier Jahre später eingestellt haben.
Erinnert sich noch jemand an Silverlight und so ein Shit?
Silverlight, wer es nicht mal kennt,
Silverlight war der
Flash-Ersatz von Microsoft.
Aber
Flash war schon
so gut wie
dead, als Silverlight rausgekommen ist,
so richtig.
Ja, das ist schwer zu sagen, was die damit machen werden.
Wie gesagt, es steht und fällt
mit der Kreativität der
Entwickler, was sie sich dafür einfallen lassen.
Am Anfang vom
iPhone. Da konnte das ja auch noch
keiner so richtig abschätzen.
Da haben halt alle sich auch nur gedacht, ja, halt
okay, und jetzt?
Echt jetzt?
Also wir sind seit Jahren
jetzt, ohne Scheiß, seit
wirklich ganz langer Zeit keine Silverlight-Anwendung
mehr untergekommen.
Und ich arbeite bei einem
ziemlichen Boomer-Unternehmen.
Ja, sie sind sehr oldschool drauf.
Die haben alles mögliche noch.
Aber Silverlight-Anwendung
kenne ich keine.
Was ist auf die Rechner von
Arbeiten installiert? Silverlight?
Nee, Silverlight kam erst
oder so.
Dann waren das
ja, guck mal, 2007.
Das ist noch gar nicht
so lange her, noch 15 Jahre her.
Man versucht das Metaverse
zu pushen. Ja gut, Meta versucht
das Metaverse zu pushen und keiner versteht,
was die eigentlich von uns wollen. Meta selbst
noch nicht mal.
Und wenn man sich MMOs anguckt,
und ich rede jetzt von älteren MMOs,
da wo MMOs noch Massive Multiplayer
waren, also sprich Zusammenspielen mit
vielen Leuten, die waren mehr mit, also
alte MMOs waren mehr
Metaverse als das Metaverse
von heute.
Ja.
Also das ist das, weiß ich nicht, das ist irgendwie
alles Bullshit-Bingo,
ohne dass die Hersteller selbst glaube ich
wissen, was sie da eigentlich so genau machen wollen.
Überlegt euch mal.
Man kann es sich kaum vorstellen,
aber MMOs
früher, also sagen wir mal MMOs
von so, was weiß ich,
2000 bis
2010 oder so, kann man schon,
die ersten paar MMOs und auch inklusive
WoW, weil
viele Leute ja der Meinung sind, weil Luftwaffe war das erste
MMO und sowas in der Richtung.
Konzert ist ja für
Classic und so die ersten Addons
auch noch durchaus mit unterschreiben.
Stellt euch mal vor, in MMOs früher,
da musstest du tatsächlich
mit anderen Leuten zusammenspielen.
Es gibt genug Leute, die der Meinung sind, weil Luftwaffe
war das erste MMO.
Da musstest du tatsächlich noch mit
anderen Leuten zusammenspielen
und zusammen Sachen machen
und nicht Solo-Questen.
Kann man sich kaum noch vorstellen,
dass der Massive-Multiplayer-
Anteil in einem MMO tatsächlich
mal wirklich Massive-Multiplayer war
und nicht, wir rennen halt
ohne unsere Quests ab und rennen ab und zu
irgendwelchen anderen Spielern über den Weg,
so wie das bei vielen MMOs heute ist.
Ganz ehrlich, MMOs ist glaube ich
für mich Gaming-technisch.
Wenn ihr mich so fragen
würde, weil das hatten wir euch öfters mal als Thema.
Ich glaube, die Entwicklung von MMOs
ist für mich die größte
Gameplay- und Gaming-technische
Enttäuschung versus
wie ich es mir früher vorgestellt habe
zu wie es geworden ist.
Das kommt auch noch dazu.
MMOs sahen modern und besser aus
als das Metaverse.
Ich habe letztens erst einen Artikel gelesen,
das Second Life, wo ich auch nicht verstanden habe,
warum das überhaupt Leute spielen, glaube ich
jetzt 20 Jahre alt geworden ist.
Aber die MMO-Entwicklung ist wirklich
und ich verstehe voll und ganz, warum Leute
RuneScape crimen.
Mein Fall ist es jetzt nicht unbedingt gewesen,
aber ich kann es verstehen.
Für mich sind MMOs glaube ich
mit die größte Enttäuschung im Gaming
überhaupt.
Ich habe mit MMOs zu spielen
damals noch Dark Age of Camelot
und ich habe auch mit dem Fabian relativ viele MMOs durch.
Wir haben
von Final Fantasy bis Rift
und so haben wir alle möglichen Dinger gespielt.
Aber am längsten habe ich tatsächlich
Dark gespielt und
das habe ich ja bestimmt
dem...
Ich spiele es ja immer noch.
Was heißt, habe ich gespielt?
Ich spiele es ja immer noch
ab und zu, wenn es neue Seasons oder neue
Over oder neue Resets
oder sowas gibt.
Und
ich habe mir halt damals ausgemalt
Also ich muss
das anders erzählen. Wenn man sich die
MMOs anguckt
die allerersten MMOs
angefangen von Ultima Online
bis Dark, bis Everquest und was
so. So die erste Welle und die
ersten paar Wellen von MMOs, die
rausgekommen sind. Und da kann man durchaus
World of Warcraft mitrechnen.
Die haben das ja wirklich massentauglich gemacht
und zum damaligen Zeitpunkt
mehr polisht als
eine... Ne, ich glaube
Meridian irgendwas war das erste MMO
aber Ultima Online war auf jeden Fall
eines der ersten.
Und Ultima Online hat den Realismus übrigens
auch total übertrieben am Anfang.
Die hatten quasi eine Welt, die
wo sie versucht haben so mit
Tiere respawnen
je nachdem wie viele andere Tiere im Gebiet sind
und sowas. Es hat überhaupt nicht hingehauen.
Es hat sich nicht geändert.
Aber zumindest, also die Sache, die ich eigentlich
sagen wollte. So die ersten paar
MMO Wellen, da hat man richtig den
wie soll man das nennen? So den
Pioniercharakter dieses Genres
gemerkt. Die Leute, die damals
MMOs entwickelt haben, die haben
MMOs entwickelt
nicht nur so nach dem Motto
Was können wir jetzt machen, dass die Leute
jetzt hier
möglichst viel grinding, möglichst viel
hier das, möglichst viel
und sowas. Da haben die nicht dran gedacht.
Die hatten damals wirklich, und das hast du in den Spielen gemerkt,
die hatten so Pioniergedanken
nach dem Motto, wir machen das
auch zum gewissen
Teil weil es geht
und dann denken wir uns aus, wie können
wir das gut integrieren. Da wurden so
viele coole Sachen gemacht und
MMOs waren damals
eher ein, nennen wir es mal
sozialer
Social
Social Sandkasten
und
das wurde natürlich mit
meistens Fantasy Inhalten angereichert
aber es war darauf ausgelegt, dass
du vieles mit anderen Spielern machen musstest
und in meiner Generation
man kann sich das vielleicht heute so ein bisschen
wie Tinder, ähnlich zu Tinder vorstellen
aber in meiner Generation
gibt es nicht wenige Leute
die heute verheiratet
sind und sich über MMOs kennengelernt
haben. Ihr müsst mal gucken Leute
in meinem Alter, wenn das sowohl
sie als auch er oder vielleicht auch er
und er, man weiß ja nie
wenn du mal ein Pärchen oder
Ehepartner oder was auch immer fragst
wie habt ihr euch kennengelernt, wenn du weißt, dass beide Spieler sind
die Chance, dass sie sich in einem MMO
kennengelernt haben, würde ich mal gar nicht
als so gering einschätzen. Also MMOs
waren quasi schon so ein bisschen das Tinder
meiner Generation
oder Jobs über MMOs bekommen haben
also in dieser
über World of Warcraft auch total viele
und
also dieser Pioniercharakter bei MMOs
in der Zeit war einfach schon
was tolles
und man hat sich damals
sicherlich auch einige
und man hat sich halt damals
und deswegen sind MMOs für mich somit
die größte Gaming Enttäuschung
die es eigentlich gibt, die Entwicklung von MMOs
und zwar
man hat sich damals
wenn man diese Games gespielt hat
so krasse Dinge ausgemalt
was theoretisch, technisch in Zukunft
möglich ist. Die haben ja damals schon
unglaubliche Sachen gemacht
ich meine, wer mal Dark gespielt hat
damals mit 5 FPS
5 FPS war doch viel zu viel
0,5 FPS
bei irgendwelchen PvP Schlachten
100 Leute auf der einen Seite
100 Leute auf der anderen, nochmal 100
von anderen dabei
das war komplette Diashow, das konnte man überhaupt nicht
richtig spielen und trotzdem hast du
dir gedacht, alter, wie geil
wird das mal sein, wenn
die das noch weiter verbessern und
sagen wir mal in 15 Jahren oder so
und jetzt gibt es so Games einfach nicht mehr
das macht einfach
keiner mehr
heute sind MMOs
irgendwelche Asia-Kreisel-Crying-Dinger
wo jeder Solo für sich spielt oder aber
Dungeon Finder
it's ready, go, go, go
lass mal schnell durchflitzen und so
ich kann die Entwicklung
nachvollziehen, aber das heißt nicht, dass ich sie
spielerisch für mich jetzt irgendwie toll finde
richtig, richtig, man hat
sich damals wirklich überlegt, boah
und man könnte ja auch
man könnte sicherlich in der heutigen Zeit
unglaublich tolle MMOs
bauen, aber so dieser
MMO-Pioniergeist ist
halt auch weg
man kann jetzt auch nicht sagen
ja, dann sollen sich halt mal ein paar Entwickler hinsetzen
so einfach ist das ja nicht
damals hast du dafür noch Geld bekommen, wenn du
MMOs gemacht hast, wenn du heute sagst
wir wollen ein MMO machen
mit denen und den Komponenten
weil es geht
und wir bauen ein geiles Game und dann sagt das erste
was irgendein Hersteller sagt, ja ist ok
aber
Monatsbeiträge bezahlt heute
niemand mehr, wie sieht denn eure
Endgame-Loop aus, dass die Leute auch ordentlich
reincashen bei uns im Shop
und dann sagen die Entwickler
ja wie, reincashen im Shop ist nicht unser Ziel
und so, ja gut, dann kriegt ihr halt kein Game
da kriegt ihr halt kein Geld für ein MMO
ja, also
da hat man sich wirklich einiges
ausgemalt, ich freue mich auch schon wieder auf
Eden Season 2
Ende des Jahres, Herbst diesen Jahres, da werde ich
wieder ein paar Runden Dark spielen, vielleicht stream ich auch
wieder ein paar Runden
das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut
und wisst ihr
das Ding ist halt, ich glaube
man erkennt das auch ein bisschen im
Zusammenhang mit den Mobile Games
Mobile Games sind viel weniger
aufwendig, als sagen wir mal
früher MMOs oder sowas waren
aber die werfen halt um ein
ein Vielfaches mehr Geld ab
deswegen muss man sich halt immer fragen, warum sollte
man dann so ein waghalsiges
Ding auf die Reihe stellen
wie damals auch MMO-Entwicklungen waren
ja, in der heutigen Zeit, du findest
kaum noch Geld und
der einfache Weg ist halt
mach lieber ein Mobile Game draus
was da alles zu wissen
ja, so und
das was du halt bei Mobile Games beobachten
kannst, ist halt, oder was du auch
generell bei vielen
modernen Games beobachten kannst, ist halt
so diese, wenn die Leute
nicht, wenn du die Leute nicht
süchtig gemacht hast, innerhalb der ersten Viertelstunde
hören sie auf zu spielen, so nach dem Motto
und das war halt nie der Ansatz
von
MMOs früher
die haben dich vielleicht
gebunden, weil nur Warcraft hat so viele Leute
angezogen, weil es für jeden was zu machen
gab, du hattest Leute, die konnten
den ganzen Tag rumrennen und craften
aber es war halt das polischste
Mainstream-MMO in dem Sinn damals
die Leute sind da halt reihenweise draufgesprungen
und
das war aber noch damals ein richtiges MMO
heute ist das ja auch mehr, wir rennen Solo
durch und questen
vor uns hin und man
darf nicht vergessen, World of Warcraft wurde
damals schon so als etwas
weichgespültes MMO
angesehen, so bei den, bei
beispielsweise den Hardcore
Everquest-Grindern, nee, haben wir noch nicht
wisst ihr eigentlich, dass der Overwatch
der, also hier, Papa Jeff
von Overwatch, der nicht mehr in
Overwatch dabei ist
wusstet ihr, dass das mal ein High-End
Everquest Raid
Progress-Guilden-Typ war
und Blizzard
hat damals in Everquest
geguckt, was es für
High-Ends, muss man sich mal vorstellen, die haben
allen Ernstes nach guten Spielern gesucht
um ihren Content
zu designen, das war noch nicht so
ah, lasst mal kurz mit der BWL-Abteilung
überlegen, wie man das möglichst massentauglich
machen können, sodass sie möglichst viele
viele Transactions abschließt
nein, die haben sich damals Top-Spieler
aus anderen MMOs geangelt
um Content zu designen
und so ist Jeff zu Blizzard gekommen
von quasi der Top-World of Warcraft
von der Top-Everquest-Raid-Gilde zu Blizzard
man darf auch nicht vergessen
wie sehr sich das gewandelt hat
Sprüche, die die damals gekloppt haben auf der
BlizzCon, da werden die heute
würden die heute öffentlich gesteinigt werden
für auf Twitter, zum Beispiel
hat sich damals irgendein Entwickler
hat sich auf die Bühne
gestellt
und hat sinngemäß sowas
ich krieg jetzt das Zitat nicht mehr so richtig hin
der hat aber sinngemäß sowas gesagt
wie, wir kennen es doch alle
den Heiler in der Gruppe, der zu doof
ist zum heilen
Leute, die haben noch mehr
solche Dinger
und dann hat er auch gesagt
wisst ihr was das ist, was man machen muss
man muss sich aus der Gruppe kicken oder sowas
in der Richtung
das haben die damals öffentlich auf der BlizzCon-Bühne
erzählt, hey hätten die heute sowas
erzählt, Twitter würde ausrasten
das wäre
der Shitstorm des Jahrhunderts
so hat sich halt alles mit der Zeit
gewandelt und heute sind MMOs
halt so
Singleplayer-Questablauf-Routendinger
und man sieht
die ganz krasse Ausgeburt
dessen davon
kennt ihr, also ich spiel sowas nicht
ich kenn das auch nur
aus Videos und irgendwelchen
blöden Appstore-Empfehlungen oder sowas
aber kennt ihr
den, ich will nicht sagen, neuesten Trend
sowas Mobile-MMOs angeht
und MMOs angeht, teilweise auch
aus Korea und Asien
das sind so solche Art
Autoscroller-MMOs
ich meine nicht sowas wie Raid Shadow Legends
was so tut als ist es ein MMO, ist es aber nicht
Autoscroller-MMOs
und zwar, das sind MMOs
die sehen vordergründig
aus wie Multiplayer-Spiele
also die haben auch irgendeine Fantasy-Welt
und sonst was, aber
eigentlich musst du nichts machen
außer das Spiel laufen haben
also das hat Autopathing
und die Helden laufen automatisch
von einer Quest
zur nächsten und sowas
ich weiß nicht
wie man dieses Genre nennt, aber ich nenne es mal
Autoscroller-MMOs
das ist zur Zeit
auch so im Mobile-Markt so total angesagt
so nach dem Motto
es hat den
den Anschein eines MMOs
aber es ist eigentlich ein AFK-Game
nein, nein, nein, nein
nicht wirklich Idle-Games
das ist schon ein Game, was du
theoretisch spielen kannst, was aber keiner wirklich
spielt, weil sie einfach Auto-Run und sowas
alles anmachen. Nicht wirklich Idle-Games
Ja, aber so
ein Blödsinn, ja. Ja, ich weiß
den MMO, das ist da, wo sie
den World of Warcraft
Quest-Text
designer rausgeschmissen haben
weil er sich lustig über
die Chefs von Spieleentwicklern
quasi über
seine Chefs gemacht hat
in einem Dialog
leider ist das
vorbei
was MMOs angeht
Ja, in Plague Desert ist der Ansatz
vielleicht erkennbar, aber
in Plague Desert ist es ja eher so, du klickst
irgendwo auf die Map, setzt einen Marker und da läuft
dann da automatisch hin. Ja, aber das
Fighten gegen die Monster und das Quest holen und so
und gucken, welche Quest du machst und so, das musst du ja
alles noch selbst machen. Das hat quasi einen Auto-Parsing
von Punkt zu Punkt auf der Map
Die Map ist auch groß
das lasse ich noch irgendwie durchgehen in Plague Desert
Ne, was ich meine, das sind Games
du startest und er spielt
das Game wirklich alleine
und du kannst es
spielen, es ist kein Idle-Game in dem Sinn
du kannst es
es wirkt wie ein MMO, aber du kannst einfach
einen Auto-Modus einschalten
Ne, ich hab kein Beispiel
wir müssen jetzt mal irgendwelche billige MMO-App-Store-Werbung
durchgucken, aber ich hab letztens erst
ein Review dazu gesehen, das sind so typische
Asia-Games auch
so irgendwas mit
Engel im Anime-Design und sowas
so typischen Games dieser Vertretung
da musst du eigentlich vom Start
weg nichts machen, du kannst quasi
Auto-Run anmachen, der geht dann in die
nächste Stadt, holt sich ein Quest, rennt zu den
Mobs, killt die Mobs, rennt zurück in die Stadt
und ey
das ist halt alles kein Game mehr
Ja, so
den Blödsinn, die Blödsinn-Werbung kriege ich
auch. Generell, Leute, ich bin
eh wieder super geflasht gewesen
Ne, Genshin Impact nicht
Genshin Impact ist ja eigentlich noch ein ganz gutes Game
wenn auch
es ein besseres Game ohne
Sinnloses reinkaschen sein
könnte, aber ne, Leute, also ich war
letztens
Nein, das mein ich nicht
ähm
ich war letztens wieder echt überrascht
wie gut
vielleicht war es auch nur Zufall, ja
aber wie gut so die Werbe-Algorithmen und
Tracking mittlerweile ist
und zwar letztens vor ein paar Tagen ging es ja in Russland
richtig ab, so vor 2-3 Tagen
und da hab ich auf Google ein bisschen danach gesucht
nach News und ich hab
so bei Twitter ein bisschen danach geguckt
so was da gerade abgeht und dann logge ich mich
ein bei Amazon
Prime Video und wisst ihr was
mir empfohlen wird als Video?
Jagd auf rote Oktober
Da hab ich gedacht, okay, ist das jetzt
Zufall oder wisst ihr wirklich
dass ich grad irgendwas mit Russland gegoogelt
hab?
Das ist tatsächlich ein ganz guter Film, ja
Aber das ist, was zum Teufel
Wie kommt ihr mir drauf, irgendeinen Film mit
Russen von 1997
oder so zu empfehlen?
Das ist ganz merkwürdig
Ich mein, das kann Zufall sein
aber ich glaub da nicht mal dran an Zufall
Ich kann übrigens
schon mal anfangen, die Proxbox
ähm, Proxbox Download
Version 8
Ist das auch die richtige
Seite? Ja, genau, die sieht immer noch so hässlich aus
wie vor 10 Jahren
Also ganz im Ernst, die Proxbox
Seite könnten sie schon nochmal
Ich mein, die sieht zweckmäßig aus, aber die könnten sie irgendwie
mal so ein bisschen im Jahr 2023
ankommen, wobei, naja doch
Sie haben ein bisschen was gemacht, die sehen immer ganz so schrecklich aus
Aber das hier sieht schon irgendwie
ein bisschen billig aus
Übrigens, was ich auch witzig fand, äh, ISO
Installer
Wisst ihr Leute, immer wieder, wir benutzen
torrent ja auch nur zu Plenums ISOs Download
Aber wisst ihr was ich witzig fand?
Die hatten einen Newspost über Proxbox 8
Und
Da ist ein Video
drin
Hä?
Haben sie das entfernt?
Hey, haben die das entfernt?
Die hatten ein Video
Die haben das entfernt?
Die hatten da ein Video drin
Hier, hier ist es doch noch
Die hatten ein Video drin und jetzt hört euch das
das offizielle Proxbox Release Video
Also die Marketingabteilung von Proxbox
muss noch ein bisschen üben, passt mal auf
So, Achtung, Achtung
Ja
Noch merkt man es nicht so sehr, oder?
Noch fällt es noch nicht so sehr auf, oder?
Jetzt wird es langsam schon auffällig, oder?
Das ist einfach
Text-to-Speech
Camu
Das ist einfach Text-to-Speech
Wenn schon Text-to-Speech
dann hätten sie ja wenigstens
das hier nehmen sollen
Da muss die Proxbox Marketingabteilung
glaube ich noch ein bisschen aufdrehen
Damit das, damit das was wird
Ja, das ist wirklich
Und wisst ihr, man könnte es tatsächlich
deutlich einfacher haben
Nein, das ist das offizielle Release Video von denen
Also dabei könnte man es
relativ einfach haben, ja
Wenn sie wirklich, wenn ihnen sonst
nichts einfällt, da sollen die
auf Fiverr gehen
und sich irgendeinen
Sprecher raussuchen
denen den Text schicken
und innerhalb von einem halben Tag haben die
ihren Text eingesprochen
Also, ich weiß nicht, ich würde so ein offizielles
Release Video nie mit
Text-to-Speech machen, da ist der Inhalt
egal, es wirkt immer so irgendwie
amateurhaft, was nicht mal über die Qualität
der Software was aussagt, ja, aber ihr wisst
wie sowas ankommt
Ich weiß nicht, ich finde das wirkt immer billig
Das wirkt dann so wie eine Drei-Mann-Klitsche oder so
Was sie wahrscheinlich gar nicht sind
So, was macht denn das?
ISO ist das jetzt runtergeladen
Downloads
Ne, es lädt noch
Das verstehe ich nicht
Also da hätte ich echt gedacht
dass Proxmox
Ich weiß nicht, wie groß ist denn eigentlich
Welche Firma ist denn hinter Proxmox?
Wie heißen die? Heißen die auch Proxmox?
Oder Wikipedia?
Gehört wem?
Oh
Proxmox Server Solutions
GmbH
Lass uns mal angucken, wie groß sind denn die eigentlich?
Suchen die Leute vielleicht?
Software Engineer Linux Kernel
Oh, das interessiert mich, was die dafür bezahlen
Meinst du die haben eine Gehaltsrange drinne stehen?
Ich meine Software Engineer Linux Kernel
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als gibt es da so viel
Alter, was ist das für eine
Seite?
Okay, die sieht wirklich aus wie 1995
Da gibt es nicht so wirklich
viele, die da drauf
passen, oder?
Job und Karriere
Rust, Leute, endlich
Wo ist die Rust Task Force,
wenn man sie braucht?
XGS
Na gut, die Oberfläche, die ist auch XGS
Das sieht man der auch an
Also mich würde, tolle Bezahlung
Also ganz ehrlich, mich würde
brennend interessieren
Was die für so jemand bezahlen
Weil da hast du nicht viele Leute, die davon
großartig Plan haben
Ja
Also das würde mich tatsächlich
Das würde mich tatsächlich interessieren
Was bei so einem Job drinne ist
Die suchen jemand, der
Ahnung von Virtualisierung
im Linux Kernel hat, da wird es nicht so viele geben
Ja
Das heißt jetzt nicht mehr Rust, sondern
Craplang
Nee, es heißt weiterhin Rust
Kann das Craplang heißen?
Ich meine, ich traue denen alles zu
Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal überprüfen
Das muss ich jetzt mal kurz überprüfen, ob das
Was, Craplang ist ein
Fork, der nach dem letzten
Was denn schon wieder für ein Drama
Sag mal, ist heute nichts mehr dramafrei?
Das ist eine fucking Programmiersprache, warum gibt es überhaupt Drama
Darum?
Okay, Craplang
Es gibt heute echt um alles Drama
Auf Clairstore sind drei
Gehaltsanträge von Proxmog, schick mal Link
Blitz
Vielleicht war es ja
Diesmal nennenswert
Nennenswertes Drama, okay, lass mal ganz
kurz das lesen, also nicht alles, sondern nur
Hier die
A community fork of a language named after a plant
fungus
Rust ist nach einem
Pilz benannt
Ich dachte Rust steht für
Rost, aber anscheinend nicht
Okay
Es ging irgendwie um Bürokratie
Alles klar
Wollte Mozilla wieder irgendwelche komischen
Dinger machen
Okay, Clairstore, zeigt mal
Bezahlung bei Proxmog
Ist halt immer die Frage
Proxmog Server
Solution ist geil und Bezahlung
Es kann nicht sein
Das ist zu wenig, dafür finden die doch nie im Leben jemand
Okay
Ein Eintrag, das ist Blödsinn
Das glaube ich
Also die können nicht ernsthaft
Erwarten, jemand der Linux-Körnel
Entwicklungserfahrung hat
Für den Hungerlohn
Never
Nee, denke ich auch nicht
Das ist auch kein echter Eintrag
Okay, lass mal kurz
Gucken
Also, warum
Gibt es jetzt
Craplang anstelle von Rust
Before Rust created as a light-hearted
Okay, bla bla bla
Okay, Moment
Was jetzt
Measured response to the growing
Concerns within the community about
The influence of corporations
Restrictive
Trademark policy
And internal political decisions
Aha
Also irgendjemand ist abgefuckt
Über Mozilla
Das wurde nicht übers Knie gebrochen
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es den
Ausdruck auch in anderen Sprachen gibt
No, was it an attempt to spread
Fear or cause panic
Aber was war denn das Problem?
Craplang fork
Why
Rust, okay, das ist noch gar nicht so lang
Her, lass mal kurz, okay
Rust has been forked
Aber
Warum? Man weiß es nicht
Drama, Drama
Keine Ahnung, was da wieder abgeht
Alter
Es kommt echt nichts ohne
Nicht mal Programmiersprachen kommen ohne Drama aus
Okay
Internal drama unveiled
Behind the scenes
Look at Rust
Das kann ich jetzt
Das kann ich jetzt nicht alles lesen
Ubuntu ist ein fork von Debian
Ich weiß nicht
Ob man das so
Wirklich sagen
Kann
Da gibt es auf jeden Fall bessere Beispiele
Für
Warum
Irgendwas mit ihrem Logo
Keine Ahnung
Alter, die haben echt Probleme
Why I left Rust
Okay, okay
Mich interessiert das jetzt
Das kann ich doch nicht alles lesen jetzt
Moment, was ist mit C++
Okay, ein C++-Experte
Würde ich auch nicht bei der Rust-Entwicklung dabei haben wollen
Also wenn
Ich alles plus kein C++
Okay, ich will
So sehr interessiert es mich jetzt auch nicht, dass ich mir das durchlesen würde
Ja
Überall Drama, Alter
Was macht meine VM?
Muss ich vielleicht mal einschalten
So
Runtergeladen ist es
Dann würde ich sagen
Können wir unsere Proxmox-VM erstellen
Lasst uns mal kurz reingucken, was neu ist in 8
Eine Sache habe ich schon
Gelesen und zwar
Dass es jetzt einen Text-Based-Installer gibt
Komm, wir gucken uns das offizielle
Announcement an
So, es gibt
Neues Dev-Enter
Gut, das werden wir jetzt hier lokal nicht auf die Schnelle ausprobieren können
Active-Directory-Authentifizierung
Interessiert mich auch nicht
Ressourcen-Mapping
USB-Geräte
Textbasierte Benutzeroberfläche
Und es gibt einen neuen CPU-Typ, okay
Aber nachdem ich schon ein paar Jahre Proxmox nicht ausprobiert habe
Also auch weder 8 noch 7 noch 6
Mal gucken
Guck doch das Video
Und dann bin ich mal gespannt
Also, die Sache ist die
Bisher hat mich Proxmox nie überzeugt
Das heißt aber nicht, dass mich Proxmox
Als Produkt an sich
Schlecht ist
Es hat sich für mich nie ergeben
Oder es hat sich für mich nie angeboten
Das zu benutzen
Ich habe dafür schlicht und ergreifend keinen Anwendungszweck gehabt
Bei mir
Auf der Arbeit, dort wo ich bisher gearbeitet habe
War Proxmox eh kein Thema
Das waren alles Millionen
Milliarden große Frankfurter Finanzunternehmen
Und Dienstleister
Da gibt es was Virtualisierung angeht
Wahrscheinlich Millionen Budget für VMware
Und nix, da ist nix mit Proxmox, kannst du knicken
Gerade auch schon aus Zertifizierungsgründen
Und aus teilweise
Ein bisschen
Vielleicht auch ein bisschen Boomer-Management
Aber da ist nix mit Proxmox
Und als ich beim Provider gearbeitet habe
Da gab es glaube ich noch kein Proxmox
Und es kam erst so auf
Aber das hat da auch keiner verwendet
Da war es auch zum größten Teil VMware
Zumal die sogar später das VMware-Geschäft
Für die Telekom ein bisschen mitgemacht haben
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnern kann
Und warum es sich für mich bei mir lokal nicht eignet
Proxmox ist relativ einfach
Mein Hauptanwendungszweck
Ist nicht wirklich Virtualisierung
Bei mir zu Hause
Ich habe eine Kiste hier hinten stehen
Das ist ein HP Microserver
Neuester Generation
Wobei die neueste Generation auch glaube ich 203 Jahre alt ist
Braucht relativ wenig Strom
Im Idle
Aber ist trotzdem relativ leistungsfähig
Also so eine Kiste ist das hier
Ja, so ein Teil
Ja, genau so sieht es aus
Mit zwei Festplatten, Einschüben
Oder sogar vier
Ja, so ein Ding ist das
Nein, darf HP mir nicht schicken
Das hat sich bei mir nie angeboten
Weil mein Hauptanwendungszweck daheim ist nicht Virtualisierung
Ich habe eine Kiste
Auf der ich
Platten drin habe
Ein bisschen Netzwerk-Share haben will
Ein paar Container laufen lassen will
Ein paar VMs laufen lassen will
USB-Sensoren anschließen
Beziehungsweise nicht Sensoren
Sensoren ist falsch für meine Heimautomatisierung
Ein paar USB-Funk-Dinge anschließen will
Ja, es ist schon Virtualisierung
Zu einem nicht unerheblichen Teil
Aber nicht nur
Und das was mich persönlich bisher
Davon abgehalten hat, Proxmox in dem Umfeld
Zu benutzen ist
Dass du dich neben der Virtualisierung
Quasi dann um alles andere selbst kümmern musst
Es ist nicht so, dass ich das nicht könnte
Ich meine, ich verdiene mein Geld damit
Und ich hatte ja auch lange Zeit
Nachischen Ubuntu
Nachischen Debian Server stehen
Wo ich das alles mitgemacht habe
Das ist an sich kein Problem
Aber ich habe mir vorgestellt
Dass mir so eine einfache Verwaltung
Für daheim doch relativ wichtig ist
Ich will nicht nur easy über ein Web-Interface
Ich wäre eigentlich der optimale Kandidat
Für so einen Synology-NAS
Hast du eine schöne Oberfläche
Ganz gute Funktionalität
Aber ich will trotzdem irgendwas Linux-basiertes haben
Synology ist übrigens auch Linux-based
Aber es ist halt nicht so richtig
Klar, was da abgeht
Außerdem will ich vielleicht
Auch ein bisschen mehr machen
Aber die Synology-Dinger
In der Leistungskategorie, wie ich es gerne hätte
Sind natürlich auch viel zu teuer
Und
Ich habe halt gerne ein schönes Interface
Nicht nur für Netzwerk-Shares anzulegen
Auch für alles mögliche, was NAS angeht
Plus ich finde es auch gut
Wenn es ein schönes Interface hat für 4Ms
Und ein schönes Interface für beispielsweise
Lass mal den ein oder anderen Docker-Container starten
Und soweit ich weiß
Hat Proxmox nur eins davon
Nämlich ein schönes Interface für 4Ms
Das Interface für Container
Ist halt wirklich sehr raw
Hier starte mal und fertig
Also du hast da keine
Kein Web-Interface zum
Ordentlichen
Also du kannst ja nicht mal einen Docker-Container starten
Du kannst LXC-Container starten, in denen du dann Docker starten würdest
Was im Endeffekt heißt
Du müsstest eigene Start-Skripts für Docker bauen
Oder Docker-Compose, YAML-Files bauen
Oder einen Single-Node-Kubernetes betreiben
Das ist mir irgendwie für daheim
Auch nicht
Von Hand bauen
Und
Für Virtualisierung sicherlich
Nice, wenn der hauptsächliche Anwendungsgrund
Virtualisierung ist, aber ansonsten hat sich Proxmox
Bei mir daheim nie angeboten
Ja, ich weiß, aber das bringt dir immer noch
Kein ordentliches Web-Interface dafür
Was schön integriert ist, da kannst du höchstens so etwas wie
Portainer benutzen und ich sage euch
Ehrlich, ich hasse Portainer
Suche gerade einen Mini-PC, den ich als
Home-Server benutzen kann, würde gerne Home Assistant
Netzwerk-Share bereitstellen
Ja, wie wärs damit?
Achso, Mini-PC, nee, dann willst du
Sowas nicht haben
Das ist zwar klein, aber es ist nicht Mini
Wie viele Festplatten brauchst du
Da drinnen? Brauchst du überhaupt interne Festplatten?
Und wie viele SSDs?
Das ist halt immer die Frage, brauchst du PCI-Express
Anschlüsse für eine 10G-Netzwerk-Karte?
Suchst du was mit 10G?
Also da muss man schon ein bisschen genauer wissen, was du eigentlich
Suchst
Was mit 10G haben, was in der heutigen Zeit durchaus
Sollen wir mal haben
Was schon Standard ist bei
Nass-Geräten, also bei Storage-Geräten
Da muss man halt gucken, wie man das drankriegt
Beziehungsweise was finden, wo es
dabei ist
Leg mir mal eine VM an für die
Proxmox-Geschichte
Also ich probiere heute mal auch ein bisschen mehr
Wir installieren das jetzt nicht nur
und entlegen nicht nur eine VM an, was übrigens auch mit
Nested-Virtualisierung überhaupt kein Problem ist, mein Rechner ist schnell genug
Wir probieren auch mal
etwas über Terraform drauf zu installieren
Ich habe gelesen, es gibt eine Terraform-Proxmox-Provider
Gucken, wie gut das funktioniert
Und wir
Clustern das Ganze auch mal
Wir bauen zwei VMs mit Proxmox auf und Clustern das
Weil das habe ich ehrlich gesagt noch nie gemacht und mich
interessiert, wie einfach oder wie
schwierig das Ganze ist. Gucken, ob wir das hinkriegen
So, Next, Next
Und wir probieren jetzt natürlich auch gleich den Text-Installer
aus, weil das ist ja eines der
neuen Features
Es ist Debian-Based
Aber letztendlich
ist es vollkommen egal, auf was man das
basieren lässt
Ja, kannst ruhig darunter speichern
Äh, tja
Eine CPU
für Kern, 8G RAM
16G RAM
Wir haben genug, ich habe mehr als genug RAM
Das passt kein Ding, 16G RAM
Machen wir mal Bridge-Networking
Wer weiß, wie das sonst so funktioniert
Gescheit, wenn man das später clustern will
Next, Next, Next
Äh, Yes, Next
Bei Proxmox bin ich mir jetzt
nicht sicher, wie das mit den Disks läuft
Wahrscheinlich braucht man erstmal nur eine
Disk, um das System
zu installieren
Dann müssen wir mal schauen, was die sagen
SunaDev, Dankeschön für den Sub
Proxmox prerequisites
Mindestens 2GB
OS
Also das Arbeitsspeicher
Circa 1GB pro Tag
Ich fange jetzt auch schon mit diesem Kram hier an
Okay
Dann installieren wir
das Ganze jetzt erstmal
mit
nur einer Platte und dann hängen wir später noch
weitere Platten dran
Proxmox geht auch nur auf einer Disk
Geht das dann aber mit Clustern gescheit?
Das müssen wir
ausprobieren
Dann machen wir die Disk tatsächlich ein bisschen größer
Ich glaube, wir haben
auch auf 10 noch ein bisschen
120G
Next
Printer kommt raus
Soundkarte kann auch raus
USB, ja
Wunderbar
Close, Finish
Muss man UEFI einschalten? Komm, wir schalten mal UEFI ein
UEFI
Dass wir auch so ein bisschen neue Hardware simulieren
Maddox, Dankeschön
für den Sub
Terraform mit Proxmox?
Das suche ich mir dann raus
Das muss ich nochmal schicken
Backweight
No
Ich habe Finished installt
Über was genau
meckert er eigentlich gerade?
Mein CD-Laufwerk?
Ne
Ah, ja, ich habe die Proxmox-CD
nicht eingehängt
Download Proxmox
ISO, jawoll
Start
Escape
Und wir wollen
booten von CD
Grupp
Wir testen jetzt den neuen Installer
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob der taugt
Das ist wohl der Oldschool-Installer
und der Console-Installer
ist jetzt neu
Kannst du mal erklären, was
Packer ist?
In welchem Kontext?
Allgemein
weiß ich nicht
Was das sein soll?
Klingt wie irgendein Container-Image
Generierungstool
Keine Ahnung
Was passiert denn,
wenn ich GPU-Pass-Through in Proxmox
mache, aber nur eine GPU habe?
Geht das soweit für das
Host-OS oder macht das Probleme?
Das kommt
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen drauf an
Ob das Host-Betriebssystem
die GPU gerade nutzt
oder nicht
Wir wollen erst mal booten
quasi ohne GPU
sodass das nicht geclaimed ist
vom Host-Betriebssystem
dass du es überhaupt mappen kannst
in der VM
Wie hast du mich denn
gefunden auf Twitch?
Zufällig oder über YouTube?
Kann man mit der VM-Workstation
4K mit Arch machen?
4K was?
4K-Videos gucken?
Ja
Ich habe keinen 4K-Bildschirm
aber 4K-Videos laufen
ohne Probleme
Ich kann es dir nur hier zeigen
Das Problem ist allerdings
Okay, das ist jetzt zu 1080p
Das Problem ist aber, was du bei
4K-Videos und 4K-Videos hast
Du kannst 4K-Videos schon
abspielen
Das Problem, was du in 4K-Videos hast ist
das ist
die Hardware-Beschleunigung
GPU-Decoding, das geht halt in VMs nicht
Das heißt, du wirst
eine sehr hohe
Das ist meine CPU-Auslastung hier oben
So, guck mal hier
4K-Video-Nature
oder so irgendwas
4K-Ultra-HD
So, guck mal
Jetzt habe ich ein 4K-Video und seht ihr das?
Für ein 4K-Video
ohne große Bewegungen
Hier
Also meine CPU
in der VM
Ich habe hier 8
CPU-Cores drin
Würde ich sagen, die sind mal
Das ist immer ein bisschen
blöd, wenn es nicht rendert gerade
Also die sind so, würde ich mal sagen
so
einem Drittel ausgelastet
8K-Video
Okay
Da wird es schon ein bisschen schwieriger in der VM
Guck mal
Vielleicht
Ja
Da ist quasi meine VM
so ziemlich ausgelastet
mit 8K-Video
Also da würde meine Notebook-Batterie jetzt auch ordentlich runter gehen
Mal schauen, ob es flüssig läuft
Schwer zu sagen jetzt am Anfang
Ja, so
Ja doch, es läuft schon flüssig
Aber ihr seht, meine CPU-Auslastung
ist nahezu 100%
Und das von einem 8K-Video
Also Videos schauen in der VM ist halt doof
mit mangelndem GPU-Decoding
Aber es sind trotzdem 8K-Pixel
die du decoden musst
Also dementsprechend, das ist sehr, sehr, sehr CPU-intensiv
Und es ist nicht so
Also mein Rechner ist jetzt nicht irgendwie
10 Jahre alt und kacke, das ist aktuell
das schnellste, was man sich kaufen kann
Ohne Scheiß
Du kannst keinen viel schnelleren Rechner kaufen
Und der ist quasi
mit 8K nahezu 100%
bei einem 8K-Video in der VM ausgelastet
Also kannst du davon ausgehen
Es ist wirklich praktikabel, sowas in der VM
zu machen
Aber das macht ja auch keinen Sinn
Wozu? Das kann ich ja auch im Haus machen
8K-Videos angucken
So, wir installieren
Wir launchen mal den Installer
Wer guckt überhaupt 8K-Videos
Vielleicht Leute mit einem 8K-Bildschirm
So
weit denken, wer das macht
muss man jetzt nicht, oder?
Aber welche 8 Kerne bekommt deine Form E
Das ist ein bisschen random
Ich glaube, das kriegt VMware immer noch nicht richtig hin
Es kann durchaus sein, dass das E-Cores sind
Aber man sieht ja prinzipiell schon, wohin die Reise geht
Also das ist sehr CPU-intensiv
Nee, am Anfang war das
verbuggt und es hat nicht dynamisch welche bekommen
Es kann aber sein, dass sie das mittlerweile
mit der letzten Version gefixt haben
Ja, das ist doch gut
Wenn mich sogar Lehrer gucken
Ja gut, Linux und Hardware-Decoding
ist eh so ein Ding
Das IHK-Prüfungsvideo
Das kam auch ganz gut an
Übrigens, falls du es nicht mitbekommen hast
Technikkeller, also den, den wir da
oder falls du es nicht mitbekommen hast
auf den wir da reaktet haben in dem Video
hat seine IHK-Prüfung jetzt übrigens
endgültig bestanden, vor 2-3 Wochen
Hacker.io
Ja, Image-Bilder
Weiß ich nicht, hab ich noch nie groß verwendet, kann ich dir nicht erklären
Ich kenne Bilder
Bilder
Was so aussieht, wie als hätte es irgendein Warhammer-Org
geschrieben
Bilder
Das kenne ich, das ist was ähnliches in der Richtung
Das ist zum Container-Images bauen
Ja, dass du zum Beispiel nicht
Docker in Docker und so ein Geschiss machen musst
Da kannst du Container-Images mitbauen
Ist, finde ich, eigentlich relativ
selbsterklärend
Echt, das brauche ich, schick her
Nee, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf
Aber 3D-Acceleration ist nicht gleich
GPU-Decoding
Also sprich, das GPU-Decoding funktioniert dann trotzdem nicht
Also du hast eigentlich
keine Chance, gescheit Videos
in der VM zu gucken, wenn du
nicht möchtest, dass dein
CPU-Lufthörer hochdreht
Und was ist der Unterschied davon zu einem einfachen Docker-File
Dass du keinen Docker brauchst, um das Image zu bauen
Die meisten
Bild-Tools, die man so verwenden kann
die fressen Docker-Files
Nur, dass du keinen Docker brauchst
Und Docker nicht zu brauchen
hat seine Vorteile, zum Beispiel
wenn du, sagen wir mal
irgendeine CI-Pipeline verwendest
zum Images bauen
die selbst wiederum
in Containern läuft
Container in Container sind oftmals gar nicht so einfach
und machen gerne Probleme
deswegen ist es schön
wenn man zum Container-Image selbst
also zum erzeugen des eigentlichen Container-Images
nicht
Container in Container machen muss
Anscheinend kannst du damit auch noch mehr erstellen
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab das noch nicht benutzt
Ja, das gibt es auch
Es gibt mehrere Sachen in der Richtung
Aber Container in Container
ist meistens nicht so schön
Das ist übrigens auch der Grund
gehe ich mal ganz stark von aus
warum GitHub Action
Runner
und GitHub Action
ja Prozesse, die das ausführen
immer noch echte VMs sind
und keine Container
zu einem nicht unerheblichen Teil
eben sowas wie Docker Build macht
und solche Geschichten in GitHub Actions
Workflows
und die Probleme machen können
wenn sie Docker in Docker sind
Oh hi IQ Shit, das muss ich mir
das muss ich mir merken für später
Das kopiere ich mir mal raus
Was jetzt?
Der Text Installer
Hängt der jetzt?
Trying to select country
Okay
Das geht ja schon mal gut los
Der Text Installer ist kaputt
Oder soll ich jetzt
irgendwie eingeben DE oder sowas
Brauche natürlich Internet, der hat Internet
Wie macht das Journal
Wahrscheinlich dann nicht mit Docker in Docker
Hä, sag mal
Seriously, ist jetzt der Installer gleich kaputt?
Direkt von Anfang an oder was?
Das wäre ja echt Fail
Ach, ich weiß warum
Weil ich Pepega bin, guck mal
Ich hab Nested Virtualisierung nicht aktiviert
Das kann sein, dass es daran liegt
dass es nicht funktioniert
Ähm
Also macht euch da mal keine Gedanken drum
Rechnertechnisch ist Performance genug da
Was ihr da vor allem ausprobieren zu können
Okay
Hallo?
Ach ne, jetzt Connect
Start
Konsole, okay, gehen wir nochmal rüber
Ach, das hab ich gar nicht gesehen
Ja, Root Shell, ich will aber den Installer haben
Ne, machst du an vielen Stellen nicht?
Guck mal an, wie viele Leute auf GitHub
in ihren Actions
tatsächlich Docker benutzen
zum Container Images bilden
Ich würd mal sagen, die meisten, die Container Images
bilden über GitHub Actions
machen das ganz klassisch
immer noch mit Docker und einem Dockerfile
Ne
Deswegen
Das ist doch genau das, was ich gerade gesagt hab
Das ist auch eines der Gründe, warum GitHub Actions
zum größten Teil
Was heißt zum größten Teil
überhaupt noch auf VMs basiert
geh ich stark von aus
Weil eben so viele Leute Docker in Docker machen
Wenn man
beispielsweise GitLab verwendet
dann ist das tatsächlich Problem
Wenn man eine GitLab-Installation hat auf Kubernetes-Basis
und versucht dort Container-Builds mit Docker zu machen
dann funktioniert das nicht
Dann muss man sich höchstens eine eigene VM machen
und dann den Runner irgendwie registrieren und sowas
Das geht natürlich auch
Ein bisschen off-topic, aber
mich würde deine Meinung interessieren
Wie lange du einen Job noch machen kannst
in Bezug auf die KI
KI wird die nächsten Jahre
sicher krasse Sprünge nach oben machen
und für deutlich weniger
benötigtes Personal sorgen
Ja, also ich
Ehrlich gesagt, ich kann in diesen
KI wird uns alle überflüssig
machen
Gesang nicht wirklich einstimmen
Ich vergleich das mal
mit einer anderen Sache
Aber da muss ich noch ein bisschen mehr zu sagen
Funktioniert, nice
Es gibt auch immer diese Aussage
dass irgendwelche
Low-Code-Plattformen
oder Design-Plattformen für Software
Programmierer überflüssig machen würden
weil dann Manager einfach Anwendungen damit zusammen klicken können
Ist nicht passiert
Aktuell auch nicht zu sehen
und wird auch nicht passieren
Bei KI
Okay, ich gebe zu
Der Vergleich war jetzt ein bisschen weit hergeholt
Aber ich denke, dass es bei KI zumindest
ein bisschen ähnlich
sein wird und zwar
KI wird sicherlich in vielen Bereichen einige Sachen
überflüssig machen, hauptsächlich irgendwelche
Sesselfurzer-Bullshit-Jobs
Ja, die du dann einfach nicht mehr
brauchst oder halt auch in vielen
anderen Bereichen, wo es nicht so
sehr KI sein wird, sondern vor allem
Automatisierung
Wo vielleicht KI nochmal
irgendwie nochmal höhere Produktivität
rausholen kann, aber viele Jobs
so klassische Jobs
wird es wahrscheinlich jetzt auch zum letzten Mal
und dieser Generation mit zum letzten Mal geben
weil vieles durch Automatisierung
und nennen wir es mal Roboter
oder sowas ersetzt wird, ja
sei es irgendwie in der Fertigung, in irgendeiner Fabrik
oder sonst was, natürlich
entstehen in diesem Zuge auch Jobs
in der Technik
aber sicherlich nicht in diesem Maße
wie andere Jobs wegfallen
So, und bei KI
ist es jetzt halt ein bisschen so
Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass
KI auch im Bereich, sagen wir mal
Softwareentwicklung
oder auch so, nennen wir es mal so
Infrastruktur
Systemarchitektur
Management, Administration
sowas in der Richtung
Einzug erhalten
wird, allerdings
gehe ich nicht davon aus, dass
KI den Job schmeißen wird, so nach
dem Motto, ja hier, ich bin jetzt euer neuer
KI-Admin, wir brauchen jetzt keine Leute
mehr, die sich hier mit den Windows-Kisten
beschäftigen, mit Linux-Kisten beschäftigen, mit sonst was
beschäftigen, nee, aber ich gehe davon aus
dass KI
durchaus in den nächsten Jahren in den
Empfehlungs- und
Entscheidungsprozess mit einfließt
was man macht und
dass in manchen Bereichen
das ist jetzt relativ schwierig abzuschätzen
wo das genau wie sein wird
dass
der eigentliche, gehen wir mal von der
klassischen Admin-Position aus
dass ein Admin
an einigen Stellen
mehr zum
KI-Überwacher
beziehungsweise zum Überprüfer wird
als zum
Selbst-Ausdenker
so, ich glaube das kann man so
irgendwie umschreiben, also sprich
es ist dann nicht so, dass
du dich nachts um drei hinsetzt
und vielleicht irgendwelche Wartungsarbeiten machst
mit drei Leuten, irgendwie neue
Software-Mission muss deployed werden, Loadbalancer
runterfahren, was auch immer, sondern
dass es vielleicht
irgendwas KI-generiertes gibt
eventuell, ja, was sagen würde
ok, ich würde das machen, dann überprüfst du das
was die KI vorschlägt
dann machst du vielleicht noch ein paar Anpassungen
da dran, beziehungsweise sagst du
KI, na, das können wir an der Stelle und so nicht machen
da gibt es dann einen Plan, der
vielleicht von der KI ausgearbeitet wird, aber ich
gehe nicht davon aus, dass man das blind
die KI durchführen lässt, man lässt
sich vielleicht einen Vorschlag machen, wie könnte man diese
Sachen am besten ausführen, man guckt
sich das an, vielleicht sind die Vorschläge
auch so gut, dass du sagst
hey, da wäre ich jetzt selbst gar nicht drauf gekommen
aber ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass dann gar kein
Admin mehr daran beteiligt sein wird
so nach dem Motto
es guckt sich keiner mehr an, es wird nachts
automatisch ausgeführt, nee, nee, das glaube ich nicht
also es wird auf jeden Fall Leute noch
im Entscheidungsprozess geben
ob das so gemacht wird, wie sich die
KI das überlegt hat und ich gehe auch
stark davon aus, dass es nachts noch irgendwelche
entweder jemand gibt, der tatsächlich
guckt, live dabei ist
da brauchst du halt kein Team mehr von 5 Leuten
sondern nur noch von einem, der nachts dabei ist
und zumindest aber
halt bereitschaftsmäßig noch
verfügbar ist
also
ich denke, dass viele Positionen
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr so in
eine Kontroll- und
Prüfposition gedrängt werden
durch KI, aber auf der anderen
Seite, auch wenn sich das Ganze rasant
entwickelt und das wird sich auch weiterhin
rasant entwickeln
weil da eben Millionen und Milliarden
wahrscheinlich reingesteckt werden aktuell
und ich meine, guck mal
an der Technologie, wo Microsoft dabei ist
wo Google dabei ist
wo sicherlich auch Facebook
irgendwie mit dabei ist und höchstwahrscheinlich
auch wenn Elon Musk
da super skeptisch ist
dagegen, der wahrscheinlich auch dabei ist
und alles scheiße findet, bis er selbst was
entwickelt hat und das dann übelst anpreisen wird
also da kann man sich davon ausgehen, wenn
so gut wie alle
high IQ Leute
da mit entwickeln und Millionen
reinstecken, dass das
eigentlich kaum noch aufzuhalten ist
egal
wie viele Leute da jetzt sagen
da müssen wir aber vorsichtig sein, das wird
gemacht und das wird nicht aufzuhalten sein
wobei ich trotzdem
immer noch auch bei den
Entwicklungen sagen muss
also, ob das jetzt
so enorm
krass wird, wie sich das manche Leute
auswahlen, bin ich
auch noch ein bisschen
skeptisch, ich meine, man sieht das
in manchen Ansätzen heute schon
zum Beispiel
also, jetzt mal
ein Beleg dafür
dass KI in der Software
durchaus coole Sachen machen kann und zwar
letztens gab es AI-based
search
wenn ich das so richtig schreiben könnte
gab es eine
News und zwar
ja
Major hat
ok, wir lesen uns mal die Überschrift durch
ich hab
letztens auch einen Artikel dazu gefunden
der nicht hinter der Paywall
war, zumindest
dort wurde per KI
ein Suchalgorithmen verbessert
und
die haben einen Suchalgorithmus
entdeckt, der schneller ist
als alle, die
bisher bekannt
waren, allerdings ist es
glaube ich
habe ich search eingegeben, ich wollte sort
ach, sort, deswegen habe ich nichts gefunden
ja, genau
ja
also, die haben einen Suchalgorithmus
gefunden
der besser ist, als das was
bisher bekannt ist, allerdings
muss man sagen, es war wohl
ich bin mir da gar nicht mehr sicher
es ging jetzt nicht, es ist kein allgemein
gültiger Suchalgorithmus, dass du sagen kannst
Quicksort hat ausgedient, sondern es geht
irgendwie so um die Fälle
wo, ich krieg's nicht mehr zusammen
wo du im Vorfeld entscheidest, ok
mein Array ist kurz, dann benutze ich den, mein Array
ist lang, dann benutze ich den
aber ich denke
also, ich denke man
erkennt schon daran, dass es
Potenzial gibt
in der Richtung
und wo Menschen auch noch nicht drauf gekommen sind
also in dem Bereich kann ich mir das gut vorstellen
und also, wo ich
davon ausgehe ist
und da bin ich mir tatsächlich auch relativ sicher
dass einige Bereiche oder einige Jobs
mehr in solche
Überprüfungs- und Entscheidungs
oder sagen wir mal so
Babysitter-Positionen
geraten werden, wo man halt schaut
ok, ist das sinnvoll
was AI Sachen da vorschlagen
oder das nochmal überprüft
das nochmal überwacht, das endgültig freigibt
entscheidet, ja das könnte ich mir vorstellen
aber ansonsten
ich habe den Eindruck, aber das kann ich nicht belegen
und das ist eher so ein bisschen auch mein Bauchgefühl
was auch so
was irgendwie auch auf Technik
der letzten 30 Jahre
die ich so mitgekriegt habe basiert
also ich bin immer ein bisschen skeptisch
bei übertriebenen Hype-Technologien
wo auf einmal von allen Ecken
Leute kommen und sagen, warte mal ab
in 5 Jahren braucht uns dann keiner mehr
oder in 5 Jahren wird das noch nie
da gewesen, es schaffen und sowas
ich denke AI ist eines der ersten Technologien
wo ich auch denke, ok
das ist wirklich mal was Bahnbrechendes
Neues, nicht so richtig vergleichbar
mit dem, was man die letzten 30 Jahren
hatte, aber
also so dieses
so irgendwelche Weltuntergangsszenarien
die sich da manche Leute
zusammen reiben oder
bald wird das alles quasi
unaufhaltbar
sein und sich selber verbessern
und es wird nie da
gewesene Technologie erfunden
werden innerhalb von ganz kurzen
also da habe ich noch so ein bisschen
meine Zweifel dran ehrlich gesagt
man darf halt nicht vergessen
das ist alles noch ziemlich am Anfang
und man sieht auch schon
einen Riesensprung zwischen
beispielsweise Chat-GPT 3 und 4
oder 3,5 ist es ja eigentlich und 4
aber trotzdem
also die Begeisterung von Chat-GPT
konnte ich persönlich ja nicht teilen bis jetzt
also als Chat-GPT neu war
gab es ja ganz viele Videos
auf YouTube so nach dem Motto
Chat-GPT erstellt mir eine Webseite bla bla bla
also ich habe Chat-GPT schon einige
Dinger gefragt und ich habe auch Chat-GPT
schon versucht Code-Vorschläge
machen zu lassen sowas
das war
also da waren durchaus gute Sachen dabei
auch gerade wenn es um
Formulierung ging und
um
wie könnte man das anders
fragen und sowas da ist Chat-GPT
nicht schlecht
aber sowas wie zum Beispiel
hallo Chat-GPT
generiere mir mal ein
.NET Programm
für den Download von
Programmen was eine Progress Bar
anzeigt oder auf Basis von
HTTP Client sinngemäß sowas
in der Richtung da kam halt
kompletter Schrott raus und selbst wenn man
Chat-GPT drauf hinweist
zum Beispiel hey also Chat-GPT
ist der Meinung, dass der .NET HTTP Client
beispielsweise eine
On-Progress
Event hat
das benutzt es
auch hartnäckig, gibt es aber nicht
und wenn du Chat-GPT
darauf hinweist
wie das HTTP Client
gar keine On-Progress Methode
hat, dann sagt Chat-GPT
ne hat es nicht und dann hat es mir eine
Windows Forms Anwendung erstellt
also komplett random
Windows Forms Anwendung mit Schleifen
ganz weird champ
also wahrscheinlich kann man mit
auch ein bisschen Erfahrung, es ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
Erfahrung wie beim Googeln, wie man Erfahrungen
gesammelt hat, also wie googelt man am besten
nur dass wir da jetzt schon 20 Jahre Zeit hatten uns dran zu gewöhnen
wie man dann
Chat-GPT doch so ein bisschen
in die Richtung kriegt oder AI
ein bisschen in die Richtung kriegt was man wissen will
aber zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt
muss ich sagen, viele Sachen hat man
trotzdem noch schneller gegoogelt, wenn man weiß wie es geht
bei manchen Sachen ist es allerdings
sinnvoll
was sagst du zu den
Red Hat News, Closed Source
wie will Red Hat das denn machen
gibt es da schon wieder was Neues
Red Hat ist auch so ein
Drecksladen mittlerweile
ich weiß nicht ob das so eine
ich weiß nicht ob das so eine Clever Idee ist
ohne die News jetzt gelesen zu haben
ganz viele, also ein
Großteil der Red Hat
Verbreitung basiert
ja auch auf Red Hat Nachbauten
und diese Red Hat Nachbauten
bringen Red Hat trotzdem Geld ein
weil bei wichtigen Systemen
ist es oftmal so, dass dann doch Red Hat
gekauft wird und doch Red Hat
Support gemietet wird und solche Sachen
und das obwohl man sagen wir mal von 100
Systemen vielleicht 80
mit früher CentOS
und heute ja
Rocky, Alma
Scientific oder was nicht noch alles gibt
laufen lässt, aber
80% hast du trotzdem
wenn es das nicht mehr gibt, ich denke
nicht, dass alle darauf
übergehen würden jetzt
Red Hat für jedes System zu lizenzieren
weil Red Hat auch nicht gerade
billig ist, ich könnte mir vorstellen
das könnte
wahrscheinlich eher Canonical und Ubuntu in die
Hände spielen
oder ja
hoffentlich nicht, aber vielleicht auch Suse
ich hoffe es ja nicht, Suse ist ja immer noch
die haben auch alle Kontrolle über ihr Leben verloren
beim Startup
CentOS gibt es in der Form ja nicht mehr
also nicht in der Form
wie es es noch bei CentOS 6 und 7
gegeben hat, aber vielleicht
spielt das eher Canonical und Ubuntu in die Hände
dass sie sagen wisst ihr was, installieren wir halt Ubuntu
und da wo wir Support brauchen, kaufen wir
und kaufen es uns halt da
ja aber das ist kein Red Hat Nachbau im
klassischen Sinn mehr
ich mache es ja ähnlich
ich benutze Windows auch noch zum Spielen und zum
Video Editieren und zum Streamen
keine Ahnung
es ist doch klar
es ist doch klar, Leute
sobald es neue, wundert das
irgendjemand, jetzt mal seriously
sobald es neue Technologien
gibt, ja
das erste was passiert bei neuen
Technologien ist Jabcock
es ist doch normal
guckt mal
warum hat sich VHS damals
durchgesetzt
oder in welchem Bereich
oder sagen wir es mal umgehend
was ist so ziemlich der einzige
in Anführungsstrichen Mainstream
Bereich, in dem
sich Virtual Reality durchgesetzt hat
wo ist das
das wundert mich nicht
tragische
Story dahinter
ich denke mir immer, müssen wir mal überprüfen
ob das stimmt, weil so tragische Storys
erzählen sich immer gut
Practice dating skills in a safe environment
das ist genau das Richtige für uns, Chat
na klar, dass es sowas gibt
DVD
solche Dinger auch
VR Chat
ist ganz weird, Champ, was da unterwegs ist
aber VR Champ
ist ein besseres Metaverse
als das Metaverse, überzeugt ihn Proxmox
guck mal, wir sind weit gekommen bei Proxmox
bis jetzt, wir probieren den Text
Installer aus
okay, next
ich lasse mal alles default, was gibt es denn
Advanced Options
okay, alles klar
perfekt
wir müssen jetzt wirklich mal weitermachen
Keyboard Layout Germany, Timezone Germany
Europa, Berlin, ja alles gut
ich würde gerne
die Language, kann man die Language wenigstens
umstellen, da muss ich
Country wahrscheinlich umstellen
Country, gehen wir mal auf
ah ne, kann man nicht machen
United States
United States oder sowas
ja
nein
okay, das ist ja Schrott
okay, machen wir Germany wieder
Proxmox hatte auch, ich weiß, dass sie einen grafischen
Installer haben, aber ich probiere absichtlich
den Textinstaller aus, weil der neu ist
okay, machen wir halt doch so
Root Passwort
pass auf Massive, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
nicht verraten, okay
bitte
ich weiß, dass die Invalid ist
Mail
at
KappaLul.com
da ist sie
PVE Invalid
sehr gut, der FQDN
alles klar
jetzt nervt man nicht rum
PVE
Mail at KappaLul.com
let's go
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
wie gesagt, wir müssen das gleich mit
Clustern und
ich installiere gleich noch einen zweiten
und da probieren wir das mit
Clustern und Terraformer
aber vorher gucken wir uns mal im Webinterface um
einfach das Invalid weglöschen
na egal
jetzt bekommt irgendein Random eine Bestätigungs-Email
nee, mir gehört die Domain
und die gibt's nicht
die E-Mail
ja, mir gehört KappaLul.com
warum die eine E-Mail brauchen
das check ich auch nicht so genau
Passwort-Recovery
das könnte tatsächlich sein
das für Passwort-Recovery ist
bei einem lokalen System kannst du
solltest du eigentlich anderweitig Passwort recoveren können
oder zumindest sollte das optional sein
warum muss man das in der Installation
eingeben, wenn ich Notifications haben will
Passwort-Reset-Möglichkeiten
dann könnte ich ja immer noch nachher konfigurieren
meinst du ich kriege jetzt Proxmox Spam
make system bootable
auf geht's
dann make es mal bootable
reboot now
bam
please remove ISO
ja
Proxmox VE, GNU, Linux
please allow me to interject
for a moment
es ist GNU
plus Linux
ok, easy, 8006
was?
ja gut, wo soll der auch günstig sein
root
vermute ich mal
standard authentication
language englisch
username safe
ich weiß
ich will auch keine valid subscription
zum testen haben
sag bloß ich brauche eine
nee oder?
das ist nur wenn ich Support oder irgendwas kaufen will
so
ich sehe standardmäßig
ein dark theme
das finde ich schon mal sehr nice
standardmäßig ist
dark theme
das Webinterface sieht tatsächlich
ich meine es ist XJS
wird das überhaupt noch weiterentwickelt
wobei das war glaube ich nie auf GitHub
oder doch
XJS
das haben wir eine Zeit lang
TV-Headern verwendet das zum Beispiel auch
ich verstehe nicht warum das irgendjemand verwendet
der noch ganz bei Sinnen ist
anscheinend
ja doch
das dark theme ist nicht von Darkweed
es hat jetzt ein offizielles dark theme
aber ganz im Ernst
das UI von
VR sieht auch nicht so
wahnsinnig viel schöner aus
wobei ich persönlich
das doch noch ein bisschen aufgeräumter finde als das
also
zwei Vs
vier
das sieht so aus
ja so sieht das aus
habe ich das nicht gerade ausgeschaltet
das Enterprise Repo
ach ne hier haben wir noch was
ja ich habe ZEV ausgeschaltet
nicht Enterprise
Update
ja schon besser
ok nice
hauen wir mal ein Update drauf
ok wir machen nebenbei noch eine zweite Installation
ich meine eigentlich könnte ich
Vm klonen
wobei ich weiß nicht wie
Proxmox das mag
wenn Vms geklont werden
wir machen noch eine zweite Vm weil ich will den Kram
ja Clustern
New Virtual Machine wir machen einfach das gleiche
ja ne ich klon es
ich klon es auch nicht
Installer Disk
Linux genau
genau
eine Prozessor vier Kerne
16 haben wir 16 oder 8
wir machen genau die gleichen Settings
Bridged
Next Next Next
Virtual Disk
120G Single Disk
Next
Printer raus
Soundkarte raus
Remove Finish
zack
moment moment
UEFI muss noch eingestellt werden
ich bin mir nämlich nicht sicher
ob das nicht vielleicht rum
könnte ich dann später egal sein
und Nesting
ja
Nesting einschalten
wir machen den Text Based Installer
oh ne wir machen jetzt
den Graphical Installer
mal gucken was mir besser gefällt
machen wir mal einen direkten Vergleich
eigentlich brauchst du 3 Server
für gescheites Clustering
nur wenn du damit rechnest dass Server down gehen
bei uns gehen natürlich keine Server down
ich hatte heute ein ulkiges
Gespräch mit einem
Personaldienstleister meine Gehaltsvorstellung
von 75k im Jahr war
wieso nicht
achso wahrscheinlich stinke ich dass er dich nicht so
einfach vermitteln kann hat er halt Pech
gehabt ist ganz einfach
hat er Pech gehabt
also ich hab Minikube schon total oft auf
Single Nodes betrieben das ist für mich eigentlich der hauptsächliche
Anwendungszweck dafür
oh ne hängt das jetzt
hängt das immer
Initial einmal und wenn man es dann
rebooted gehts
was ist das denn
was ist da los
jetzt gehts
keine Ahnung was das ist
ähm
ok jetzt können wir uns
zur Abwechslung den UI Installer
für angucken
ja gut im Endeffekt hab ich ja auch nicht weiter geklickt
bei der Platte
ok es ist exakt
der Text Installer in UI
kappalul.com
Passwort auch super
top secret wieder nicht verraten Chat gibt
äh PVE
hab ich einen Bindestrich gemacht
oder
ne ich glaub ich hab nen Bindestrich
30 ok next
was
wie hab ich den anderen genannt
wie hab ich den anderen nochmal genannt
äh
Shell
Hostname
PVE.PV
äh es ist halt doof
ich nenn halt mal
minus PVE 2
was eigentlich
nicht so ganz richtig ist
aber da wird sich wahrscheinlich nicht dran
nicht dran stören
install
Hostname ist egal
dann ist ja gut
wenn Hostname egal ist
dann probieren wir jetzt mal gleich aus die Dinger zu Clustern
noch nie gemacht
welches Filesystem hast du genommen default
weiß ich was default ist
bei einer Platte macht es aber nicht so viel Sinn
doch doch vielleicht für VMSnapshots
und sowas
schauen wir mal
ich hab jetzt echt alles mal default
ich hab jetzt alles mal default gelassen
mal gucken was passiert
oder ob alles geht
ja Snapshots stell ich mir halt
einfacher vor mit ZFS unten drunter
also der Installer
ist neu
aber nicht der grafische Installer
in der Management
Konsole weiß ich nicht
dafür kenn ich mich persönlich mit Proxmox nicht so sehr aus
aber wir probieren jetzt gleich mal aus
zwei Kisten zu Clustern
mal gucken wie gut das funktioniert
wie funktioniert Cluster ohne Shared Storage
wahrscheinlich gar nicht richtig
aber ich bin mal gespannt was er sagt
ja doch du kannst ja theoretisch alles replizieren an Disks
aber
ist halt auch irgendwie bisschen doof
gerade wenn mal das Netzwerk ruckelt
und beide denken sie sind Master und sowas
stell ich mir ein bisschen schwierig vor
aber letztendlich es geht ja hier nicht darum
ein wirklich gut funktionierendes High Availability Setup
zu machen sondern einfach nur mal zu schauen
wie lässt sich das ganze Clustern
ok jetzt wird er gestartet
alles klar
so dann machen wir das mal auf
also wir haben einmal den hier am Start
und
wir haben den hier
am Start
beide super
krass komplizierte nie dagewesene
Passwörter
ach fuck jetzt muss ich den Mist hier auch noch machen mit den Subscriptions
oder was
boah das ist ja nervig
ey wo waren das jetzt nochmal
Repositories
so diesen ganzen Mist
ausschalten
und dann hinzufügen
für das
No Subscription
Shell
Update
geht bestimmt auch irgendwie übers Webinterface
schneller
so Upgrade
yes
ok
so wie würde man
Cluster
wie würde man das ganze
Clustern irgendwas
Replication
ok wie würde man
Data Center wie würde man so
Cluster
Create Cluster
Cluster Name Keckel
Cluster Network 1 3
ja ja ok Create
was ist der Download Knopf hier
ach das downloadet das Log
wen juckt denn das Log
Status
Output ist das jetzt fertig
ah das war es jetzt
ok ich denke mal
der ist automatisch drin
Copy the Join Information here and use it
on the Node you want to add
ok das sind meine
Join Information
ok
dann gehen wir jetzt auch mal hier auf
Cluster Join Cluster
Enter Password
1 2 3 4 5 6 was anderes
habe ich ja nicht
Join Keckel
warum
ok
Fehlermeldung nicht hilfreich
beide Nodes heißen
oh
irgendjemand hat doch gerade noch gesagt
Hostname egal
richtig krass rein
ok
wie ändert man das
ganze jetzt hier
System
Host
Network
in Host
nee oder
soll ich hier wirklich
ernsthaft
ist das so gedacht
kann ich mir kaum vorstellen
dass das so gedacht ist
ok
Proxmox Change Hostname
ok nein das muss man
tatsächlich so machen
das ist tatsächlich der gewollte
ok
ja das ist ja abfuck dumm gemacht
alter das ist ja richtig
dumm ok
mal noch ein Shell auf
Connection Failed ja wahrscheinlich weil der
Hostname jetzt nicht mehr geht
Reboot dumm
ja warum gibt es das nicht in einem UI
anklicken Hostname ändern
unter der ich meine der Vorteil von
so einem Management Interface ist doch gerade
dass ich nicht direkt in die Dateien zum editieren muss
und dass ich nicht irgendwie eine Datei vergessen
kann beim editieren und sowas
das ist doch dumm dass sie hier automatisch
irgendwelche Datei also für so
simple Sachen wie Hostnamen anpassen
hin muss
nee das ist das ist blöd das gefällt mir schon mal
nicht
da sind wir wieder
Nice
geht nicht mehr
die Holzhammer Methode Leute
zum PC Speaker abschalten einfach
einfach das Kernel Modul anladen
ETC
Hostname sollen wir noch anpassen
wie kein Wim drauf
KVE-1
habe ich das Ding genannt
ETC Host
denkt das jetzt richtig so
Reboot so hoffen wir mal dass das Ding jetzt
hochkommt
wir werden den Cluster übrigens nochmal löschen bei der
Gelegenheit
ähm
Cluster ist nicht mehr löschbar
wenn man einmal
drin ist oder
dann
dann deadge
weil ich hätte jetzt hier eigentlich auch den
Hostnamen noch geändert
kannst den Knoten löschen
das ist ja nur er selbst aktuell
und ich wüsste nicht wo ich hier irgendwas anklicken
könnte für den Cluster
gibt ja kein
Delete Knopf oder so
wie ist denn das aufgebaut
ah ok er geht jetzt wieder
er heißt auch richtig
ich habe einen HP Microserver
jetzt heißt er PVE-1 und der heißt PVE
ja ok das sollte
funktionieren ist zwar nicht schön aber es sollte
funktionieren Cluster
Join
1,2,3,4,5,6
jawoll
hat funktioniert oder
was
ist das Problem
aber jetzt geht es auf einmal
ok alles klar wir haben einen Cluster aus 2 Nodes
wir haben PVE und PVE-1
die Namen sind ziemlich hardcore
PP gar das gebe ich zu
aber man konnte das mit dem Cluster nicht mehr rückgängig
machen also
haben wir jetzt halt so komische PP gar Names
ist ok
es ist halt PVE und PVE-1 alles gut
so
dann
legen wir doch bei der
gerade mal an der Stelle
ist das jetzt der Master
oder ist das egal
wenn ich jetzt was mache macht das überall
dann probieren wir doch jetzt mal aus
wie gut das mit dem Cluster funktioniert
Debian
Debian 12 Iso
wir machen ein Minimal Debian Iso
wie heißt das
ein HP Microserver
die die aktuelle Generation ist
machen wir jetzt mal auf die
Schnelle weil das geht wirklich zackig
eine Debian Install
und dann gucken wir mal was
passiert wenn wir einfach einen von beiden
ausschalten
also wir machen jetzt hier
auf PVE-1 eine Debian Install
da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
du kannst für Proxmox auch fertige
Root Images laden
also sind die schon eingebaut also
probieren wir mal
äh ne Moment
ne ne so gehts nicht
Create4M das will ich haben
auf Node PVE-1
Name
Keck W
Resource Pool
das ist ok
Storage ist lokal ne ich hätte davon ausgegangen
dass er sich irgendwie zynkt
Next
Iso Image
ne gibt es nicht
gibt kein Iso Image
wie bekomme ich denn überhaupt ein Iso Image
hier rein
wow
ok da kann er aber ganz schön viel
wie bekommt man Iso Images hier rein
so
Storage
die Nodes aufmachen
ach so
ok
Iso Images
Upload
ok man kann das auch direkt
ja gut
ist jetzt nicht so wild
muss man halt wissen
so und jetzt
Create4M
Keck W
Next Local Image Debian
ja wunderbar
System ja ganz ganz toll
so brauchen wir das
ja soll mir auch alles recht sein
BIOS ganz toll wunderbar
ja Discs 32G
naja 8G reichen dafür
ach 16G
ja Kors
naja 2G
ok
Memory
da gibt es keine Presets
aber eigentlich reichen für ein Debian
easy aus
Next
ja wunderbar
Start After Created
ok Finish
let's go
hier ist die 4M
Konsole
Moment
was habe ich mir da runtergeladen
grafische Installer
habe ich bei Debian noch nie benutzt
was ist das für eine krasse
Auflösung
Europe
Germany
hier funktioniert jetzt übrigens auch die Tastatur
US
German
das Image ist für Netinstaller auch viel zu
groß
aber ich bilde mir ein ich habe irgendwas mit Netinstaller
runtergeladen
perfekte Hostname
gut Passwort
super komplex
Max
ja auch nie dargesehen
super geheimes Passwort
Netinstall ist so groß
ich habe doch letztens
nicht Netinstall
das Cloud Image ist das kleine
das ist auch das was wir für den 4M Champ
benutzen hier
4M Champ
Run
ja
Bloop
Debian Cloud Images werden da runtergeladen
und die sind deutlich kleiner
ja
die sind viel kleiner
und da kommst du auch mit kaum
Discomemory aus
ich glaube mein Docker ist übrigens kaputt
wahrscheinlich kackt das jetzt
was labere ich denn für ein Blödsinn
auf Docker Basis dann müsste es jetzt so funktionieren
eh sind wir doch hier
haben wir doch unsere Debian 4M am Laufen
ich hab alles wieder weg
äh
ja äh was
no
Germany
äh
TU Chemnitz Besse so weiter
ich bin mal gespannt was
passiert wenn ich
wenn ich jetzt einfach den Node ausschalte
oder wie man
Migration oder so
ausschaltet
wahrscheinlich geht das nicht
weil ich kein Shared Cephs oder sowas
alter was will der mir denn alles
für ein Schrott installieren
dann ist es wahrscheinlich kaputt
dann frage ich mich aber wo der Sinn
aktuell vom Cluster ist
hat es ja dann nicht so wirklich
install
yes
was
was soll die Installation gerade von mir
wo Crap installiert werden soll
alter ist eine Festplatte drin wo soll es denn
drauf installiert werden wollen
komische
Frage
so continue wir sind fertig mit der Debian
Installation
Chat
war das falsch
was ich bei Crap ausgewählt habe
habe ich
hätte ich mir das vielleicht mal ein bisschen
angucken sollen was da steht
hahaha
naja
da können wir uns bei der
Gelegenheit auch gleich mal angucken wie macht man
Ctrl Alt Entfernen hier drauf
Ctrl Alt
Escape from Boot Menu
ok nice so anscheinend
ist die CD
überhaupt noch gemountet jetzt
DVD
ja die ist noch gemountet install
ok
dann muss ich den Kram nochmal machen
alter
englisch
europa germany
das hat jetzt nur 2 Minuten gedauert
german
ja so läuft das halt als Senior Linux Engineer
da kann sowas schon mal vorkommen
so ausnehmen Debian
Domain weg
Highly Secure Professional
Root Passwort
Max
Guided
yes
du musstest bei dem Keller gerade eine Maus einfangen
nicht Logitech oder so
sondern so ne richtig echte
ja ich hab zwar ne Katze
aber wahrscheinlich wäre die auch nicht in der Lage gewesen
die Maus zu fangen die hätte wahrscheinlich Angst vor der Maus
hatte die RGB
berechtigte Frage Chat
würde mich auch interessieren
hatte die RGB
no
yes
ja hier
next
da wüsstest du wenigstens immer wo sie ist wenn die RGB hätte
no
so was ist das eigentlich für ne bescheuerte
Installation die mir standardmäßig genau im
Desktop Environment aufschwätzen will
so jetzt müssen wir aufpassen Leute
jetzt müssen wir aufpassen
jetzt darf ich nicht wieder einfach nur Enter
Enter drücken und gut ist
ok install Crap
to your primary drive
yes
Enter ah
ok hätte ich mal das
richtige ausgewählt nicht einfach nur Enter gedrückt
naja
so ist das halt wir brauchen keine Tests weil wir
keine Fehler machen so
choose Reboot yes
das sieht doch schon
deutlich besser aus
ok nice Debian booted
alter wie schnell hatten das
gerade den Starter
Route 123456
da sind wir am Start
was haben wir
was haben wir denn
2.141
so
jetzt testen wir mal unser Cluster Shit
also kann ich den Kram
jetzt von Cluster 1 auf Cluster 2
schieben Migrate ok
kann man irgendwelche
Replication kann man einschalten
Add
Create
Replicate Feature
on Volume
die Fehlermeldung ist nicht hilfreich
nimm mal die ISO raus
wie nimmt man die ISO raus
die ist schon raus
und was hat
er jetzt für Schmerzen
muss ich jetzt Shutdown dafür
dass das rausfliegt oder wie
ja gut das ist bei KVM
beziehungsweise
wenn man das mit dem Wirtmanager oder so macht ist das ja auch so
ok aber das wird wahrscheinlich
sein da fehlen wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Sachen
Replication
Create Missing Replication
Feature on Volume
ok was
möchte es mir sagen
kann man da auf Help klicken
ok probieren wir das mal aus
Add
Help
nee
Missing Replication Feature
on Local Volume
You need a ZFS based
Storage in order to use Replication
aha
ok
warum ist denn standardmäßig kein ZFS
das ist ja doof
aber das ist ja kein Problem wir können einfach eine zweite Platte dranhängen
auf der machen wir ZFS oder
das sollte doch eigentlich
ohne Probleme möglich sein
probieren wir das doch einfach mal aus
Settings
hinzufügen wir machen mal ein bisschen kleineres
kleineres Laufwerk ist im Prinzip auch
vollkommen egal
Finish
so
gucken wir mal ob wir die neue Platte schon sehen
also auf dem sind wir jetzt ja hier
hier Network
sieht man ja oder
nee wo sehe ich denn
wo sehe ich denn was für eine IP mein jeweiliger
Note hat
das hier oben sagt ja ja nichts
ach das ist 31
gerade
wir sind hier auf dem
ok so jetzt ist die
Frage wie kriegen wir die neue
Platte da rein
lass mal überlegen
Storage
Disks
Detect New Disk
interessiert ihr nicht
aber wo habe ich die Disk jetzt hinzugefügt
ich füge eine Disk bei beiden
hinzu dann ist es letztendlich auch egal
Disk
Next Create 50
jawoll
so jetzt haben beide eine neue Disk
wahrscheinlich muss man die Dinger Rebooten
was aber schon echt blöd wäre
das könnte aber auch mit meinem
Vmware Dings zusammenhängen
aber
dass man da neu starten muss ist weird
Champ
das kann eigentlich nicht sein
ich meine ich kann eine Shell aufmachen
Rescan
ach gibt es nicht ok
siehst du die Disk
äh
ne sehe ich nicht
ich müsste
sowas wie Rescan machen
Echo 1 nach
boah
weiß ich
ok ich reboote mal
schau mal unter
Datacenter Storage
Datacenter Storage at ZFS
bin ich mir unschlüssig
was das mir sagen soll
aber das ist doof
das muss übers
übers Webinterface
irgendwie gehen
Disks
ok der erkennt die Platten wirklich nicht
das könnte wirklich mit meinem
Vm Setup zusammenhängen
durchaus möglich
wir rebooten
das Ding jetzt mal
also ich könnte mir vorstellen dass das bei
echter Hardware tatsächlich funktioniert
das schieben wir
dem jetzt mal nicht an
ich schaue wirklich auf mein Vm Setup
dass das nicht funktioniert
User bin Rescan
äh stimmt
ich muss beides rebooten
da muss ich jetzt auf den
ne
nehme ich nicht
reboot
ok der ist wieder da
haben die nicht jetzt irgendwie
eine Cluster IP das da drauf kommt
warum muss ich eigentlich auf die einzelnen
Nodes im Cluster
ok so der erste ist wieder da
gucken wir doch mal
Disks aha da ist es
so wie legt man jetzt sowas an
legt man das hier drüber an
Storage
und vor allem
warum steht da was von
Local
das check ich jetzt nicht so
ganz
warum man es auf Datacenter Level
und auf
Node
Level machen kann
na gut
ZFS Create ZFS
Single Disk
ja wunderbar
blablabla ja ok gut
Name
Pogu
Pool
Pogu Pool wurde erstellt
da sind wir
am Start
ach jetzt steht er auch hier drinnen der Pogu Pool
ok so
muss ich das jetzt auf
beiden anlegen oder hat er das jetzt schon
auf beiden gemacht
nee beim anderen
Node Haken raus
wie was wie wo
ich will
jetzt mal gucken ob ich den Kram jetzt
migraten kann
nee das wollte ich nicht gerade aus
Replication wollte ich machen
Add
Target auf PVE
Missing Disk
achso weil ich das hier
noch nicht angelegt hab
also machen wir das auch mal hier
Storage
ZFS Create
nennen wir das mal auch
Pogu
Pool
darf das überhaupt den gleichen Namen haben
ja das
jetzt müssen wir die VM wahrscheinlich noch verschieben
genau wir müssen die VM noch verschieben
die liegt auf dem falschen
Laufwerk
so da geht man wahrscheinlich
ich rate jetzt einfach mal
VM Disks
geht man da hin
nee
das ist die Frage
wie kriegt man den jetzt von da nach da
Migrate
Hardware
Local Disk
ach hier
Edit
Disk Action
Storage
Target Storage
Pogu Pool
sehr schön
High Speed SSD Storage
by the way
ich weiß nicht ob du das in deiner Ausbildung
lernen wirst kommt ein bisschen drauf an
was ihr da
benutzt im Enterprise Umfeld
ist Proxmox nicht so wirklich
sag ich jetzt einfach mal zumindest ich kenne keinen
im Enterprise Umfeld der Proxmox verwendet
ist das jetzt fertig
geht das durch
so jetzt ist das Ding gemoved
auf die andere
VM
ok jetzt starten wir das
das wird jetzt vom Pogu Pool gestartet
jetzt können wir wahrscheinlich auch sagen
Replication
so wir wollen
das replicat
hä
du sollst das überhaupt nicht
dahin replicaten
und jetzt
die
war bestimmte Haken drin
ok das ist sehr hilfreich welche Haken
hier sind bestimmt viele Haken
muss man vielleicht sagen was
das Default Migration Target
oder sowas ist
dass der halt
standardmäßig
den Pool hier verwenden will
Erstellung ZFS
welche Haken
wo
Add Storage ja
verkehrt
warum ist Add Storage verkehrt
Add Storage klingt doch eigentlich sinnvoll
also
Add Storage klingt für mich nicht
was beim zweiten Node
ja aber wo ist das Problem
ist doch
ist doch ok dass das als Storage geedit wurde
ich meine
es wäre natürlich schön wenn es eine Hilfe gäbe
wenn man das nicht adden darf
weil Add Storage klingt ja erstmal nach
was wo man Storage adden will
die Sache ist aber die
warum will der das überhaupt aufs andere
Migraten
vor allem warum kann man
das Target
der hat bestimmt
so ein Default Target
startet die VM noch
von der alten SS
sollte es eigentlich nicht
der startet von Pogu Pool jetzt
wenn beim zweiten mit gleichem
Namen dann gemeinsamer Pool
was auch immer
hä
ich muss es aber noch doppelt anlegen
das ergibt doch keinen Sinn
du musst die alte Disk noch löschen
der hat die kopiert und nicht verschoben
doch egal
ok ok Chat Chat
du hast zwei Pools gemacht
ja und
ich weiß nicht wo das Problem ist
ich muss doch auf beiden
Nodes also ich habe keine Ahnung wie das gedacht ist
aber ich muss doch auf beiden
Nodes den Kram anlegen oder nicht
naja gut das hat ja kein Sinn
ich muss es jetzt mal ein bisschen ausprobieren
Twitch Chat ist ja immer sehr widersprüchlich
was die Leute erzählen
so also wir haben
ein Pool hier und ok die Disk ist da
hier ist
auch noch was drauf ok
Cannot Remove
ach so
die steht ja noch als
unused drinne
ok da muss man sich dran gewöhnen
Replication
vielleicht gehts jetzt
jetzt funktioniert es
von wegen irgendwelche Haken oder sowas
ich habe einen Channel gefunden
der 100% nicht gefällt
wieso macht der C++ oder was
oder was ist da
C++ Chat
genau das richtige
für mich
C++ was machen die
C++ Leute so gerade
20 Rechner mehrere Stunden
sondern 20 30 Rechner mehrere Stunden
damit dieses Programm läuft
C++
hör mal Plus auf
und jetzt replicatet das
Duration 11 Sekunden
Status ok
bedeutet das jetzt
wenn ich den Node ausschalte
dass er das live migraten kann
zum anderen
wir testen erstmal eine Migration
wenn das andere noch da ist
ok Migrate
und weiter
du möchtest Golang lernen
ja mach doch das
die haben ja nicht so ein offizielles Tutorial
das war doch ganz gut
ok Migrate
mach das offizielle Tutorial
wenn es sowas gibt ist das immer top
und dann kannst du dich auf Youtube umgucken
da gibt es sicherlich gute Tutorials
gerade für Go
gerade für Go ist
Youtube super Quelle
guck mal Easy
und jetzt lief die 4M
ok jetzt müssen wir natürlich auch mal checken
wie High Available
das Ganze ist
hier Root
IP Add
also Ultimativer Test
wir machen mal ein Ping
Ping Ping
192 168
mal gucken
ob irgendwas Timeoutet oder verloren geht
oder sowas
beim
Migraten
ok Migrate
Target Node auf den anderen
Migrate
das ist echt nicht verkehrt
es hing mal kurz
zweieinhalb Sekunden
und dann ist die 4M wieder da
gut die 4M ist auch easy
die hat nichts laufen, die hat nicht viel Last
die ist klein
aber das macht doch einen ganz brauchbaren Eindruck
ja
ja warum nicht
was ich mich frage ist
was ist der Sinn dieser
Replication an der Stelle
wenn es nicht dazu führt, dass wenn ich den Node ausschalte
die 4M rüber geschoben wird
ok testen wir das mal
wir schalten jetzt Node 1 aus
das ist der hier
meine Benamung sagt halt
so ein bisschen
also wir haben hier
PVE 1
hat Network
die hier 131
kann man das ja ein bisschen
umsortieren
so wir machen jetzt
die Hardcore Variante
Power
Power Off
die Replication wird nur mit einem Storage
wie soll denn die Dist auf den anderen kommen
naja der synkt die einfach rüber
ich hab da schon was von
irgendwelchen Network Storage Sachen
gesehen
wie heißt das Ding
DNBD
das ist auch Netzwerk Storage
so zwar die Oldschool Variante
wir machen ein Raid 1 über Netzwerk
aber geht doch
Power Off
wir schauen einfach mal was passiert
der Node ist weg
mal gucken wann er es checkt
Node ist weg ok
und jetzt
Pause Champ
Node is dead
ok das juckt hier nicht
No Route to Host
ich brauch da ein bisschen
ach das geht nicht
man braucht wirklich 3
ok Migrate
Target Node
RIP
ich versteh den Sinn von der Replizierung
aber nicht
ich mein
ach ich hab jetzt die Disk
ja Moment
aber die Disk hab ich vielleicht nur drauf weil ich einmal
Migrated hab
hast du eingestellt dass der automatisch wechselt
aber ich hätte gedacht dass ich zumindest von Hand
machen kann
das heißt ich hab jetzt die Disk hier rüber
und ich müsste jetzt quasi von der Disk
ne neue
ok das ist weird
muss man sich wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schlau machen wie das gedacht ist
also ich denke schon dass es das
ganz gut kann
wenn man weiß was man da treibt
ja was juckt mich
Splitbrain in dem Fall
in dem Fall ist es doch klar einer ist noch da einer ist weg
die können ja auch nicht
Splitbrain sein weil es ist ja nur noch einer da
der wird halt der eine aktiv
ja gut das ist ja auch richtig in dem Fall
also ja ich geb euch recht
3 Nodes macht schon Sinn aber jetzt
mal probieren
ok da ist er wieder
so was kann man hier sonst noch einstellen
also den Sinn von
Replication hab ich
Replication ist anscheinend wirklich nur
Disk oder was
was ist das da
Storage Replication
ok das ist wirklich nur Storage
aha
ahja ok
das ist tatsächlich nur für Storage
ok das muss man wissen
kann doch irgendwie Sinn das ist ok wenn man das weiß
jetzt ist nur die Frage kann man
kann man irgendwie
ok Roxmox
Migrate
Node Failed
so
man braucht wahrscheinlich Netzwerk Storage oder
ok
ok wir haben einfach kein sinnvolles Setup
dafür
man braucht Shared Storage
ergibt ja auch irgendwie Sinn für sowas
ergibt ja auch Sinn
dass es nicht gescheit funktionieren kann
den Vorteil
hast du sogar
du hast sogar noch einen Vorteil wenn du
einen Storage hast
dann hast du nochmal einen zweiten
Weg worüber sie sich im Zweifelsfall
einigen können wer Master wird und sowas
ja ergibt schon irgendwie Sinn
dass das nicht funktioniert
Shared Storage
ok ja ergibt Sinn
hat das irgendwas eingebautes
zum Thema Shared Storage
kann ich mit einem Klick sowas erstellen
wobei
ist natürlich bescheuert das läuft ja dann trotzdem nach wie vor
auf einem der beiden Nodes
also ich bräuchte dann sowas wie ein
NFS oder ZEV
auf mehrere Sachen verteilt oder sonst was
da bräuchte man
eine extra Kiste
aber wisst ihr was ich noch nicht ganz gecheckt habe ist
ach
Moment
wenn ich hier was hinzufüge
dann dreht sich das immer
um
den lokalen Storage angeschlossen
an den jeweiligen Nodes
egal ob ZFS
oder sonst was und wenn ich sag
Datacenter Storage
da kann ich dann Cluster
hinzufügen ja also
NFS, Shared, ZEV, Samba
ok das macht natürlich Sinn
ja
aber ich habe keine Ahnung von ZEV
ich bräuchte jetzt wahrscheinlich noch eine dritte
LVM für irgendwas
ja ok
oder
PTFS was will das denn hier
ich verstehe nicht so ganz
wie ich
datacenterweit
ein LVM
hinzufügen kann
das ist doch dann trotzdem an eine meiner Nodes angebunden
du kannst links
in der Seitenleiste von datacenter
ja aber ich brauche doch trotzdem noch
hier
ja aber das bringt ja nichts
ich mein oder reicht das dann schon
wenn es auf beiden Nodes läuft
dann checkt das oder wie
wir nehmen das
äh ja no
äh yes
also da muss man sagen da ist die
vmware Experience was UI angeht
und sowas schon irgendwie ein bisschen runder
bei vmware musste ich es überhaupt nicht interessieren
dass da ein Linux drunter ist
vmware war mal ursprünglich irgendwas
was es jetzt ist keine Ahnung
ich als alter Linux
äh enjoyer
ich find das gar nicht so übel
reloading rp to load new
safe library
ok
hat das jetzt funktioniert
configuration public network
ja bestes
best public network
next
depending on your setup
some of the following steps
are required to start
finish
und
jetzt
und jetzt
und jetzt muss ich auf den anderen
node und da auch noch hinzufügen
ne
ah
ok hier muss man das jetzt auch noch
hinzufügen
ja vmware ist glaube ich
mittlerweile selbst gebaut aber ich vermute mal das
ganz tief immer noch ein redhead
drunter ist es war zumindest früher redhead
based
es kann aber auch sein dass es mittlerweile gar nichts
mehr damit zu tun hat
ok
komm mal connection to
er hat es gecheckt direkt
ne
er hat es schon gefunden
er hat es schon kapiert
oder
für den privaten gebrauch ist ESX zumindest
kostenlos aber da fehlen ja bestimmt ein paar Sachen
ich weiß nicht was da die Beschränkung
ich weiß nicht was ich machen muss
ja aber da müsste ja zumindest
da müsste ja zumindest
es ist ja nichts drinnen
und es ist auch
muss ich den noch ein paar leere
disks geben
pools
braucht man sowas
ich rate mich komplett durch gerade
leute ich hab kein plan
ok ne das war es schon mal nicht
jetzt habe ich einen pool der sich
keckel nennt
weil die frage was das macht
jetzt ist auf beiden
ja jetzt ist auf beiden nodes der storage
aber der ist ok der ist available
ok das sieht schon mal nicht
verkehrt aus nicht dass ich irgendeine Ahnung
hätte was es ist
what is DMPD used for
das haben wir doch schon oder
das ist irgendeine uralte Anleitung
das muss man bestimmt
nicht mehr so machen
so jetzt haben wir hier den kram drauf
available
ok das heißt
ja das DMPD nichts mit
zeff zu tun das weiß ich auch das ist halt
uralte Anleitung ich glaube
DMPD hat er auch benutzt für Replication
die ganze Zeit das hat man auch gesehen
so
pool disk action
move
target storage auf keckel
welche disk nimmt er jetzt
überhaupt und was
passiert gerade passiert
überhaupt was
achte jetzt was
da stand 0 bytes available
wait a minute ok
wirklich
storage
wo stand
das
pools
ah
was ne da steht
used
dass 0 bytes used sind
im log
das ist schon ein bisschen
ach beim verschieben stand das da
das habe ich jetzt
gar nicht gesehen
wo stand das disk action
move storage
ach hier available
ok wie gut das ist die Frage
wie kriege ich jetzt da was rein
es heißt ok
wir machen das jetzt
wir hängen da jetzt einfach testweise noch was dran
OSDs
zeig
Moment
wo ist
OSD
default
create OSD
ach hier
mache ich das jetzt
Moment
DB disk
ich habe so keinen Plan davon
was ich hier eigentlich treibe
ich habe auch keine Ahnung von
was ist denn ein OSD
Object Storage
Ne ne ne
wir gucken keine
Tutorials
Leute wir hängen jetzt einfach mal ein paar Disks dran
Next
Disks hier
Hard Disk
Create new disk
50G
gib ihm 50G
Next
hinzufügen
Disk
Next
ok
so
und jetzt sind wir einfach mal ganz hart drauf
wenn die wieder da sind
dann sollten sie zumindest jetzt noch freie Disks haben
und dann probieren wir das mit OSD
aus
auf
da ist er wieder
die brauchen wahrscheinlich kurz bis sie es gecheckt haben
dass sie wieder da sind alle
auf guck da
Bäm erste ist schon da
alles klar OSD
Ceph
OSD
Default
da ist wahrscheinlich nichts
oh der andere ist auch wieder da
Create OSD
guck mal SDC ist da
DB disk
DB disk ist das sowas
für irgendwie so ein
Right Lock
ich wähle jetzt einfach mal random da was aus
Bäm beste DB disk
braucht man das überhaupt?
ne das geht auch ohne
ok SDC
da haben wir das gleiche
jetzt nochmal auf dem anderen Node
ah guck mal da
jetzt haben wir auch Platz
ok
und
muss ich jetzt nochmal einen OSD
anlegen
ok ergibt ja auch Sinn
dass das auf jedem Node laufen muss
alles klar hat er gecheckt
ok und jetzt
und habe ich jetzt hier Speicher
drauf
Usage aha
jetzt habe ich Speicher drauf
alles klar also jetzt können wir
hier hingehen Hardware
Disk Action
Move Storage
auf den
Kackel
Dings Pool
Move
ah guck mal jetzt funktioniert das auch
wenn auch ziemlich lahm aber jetzt
funktioniert ok das muss man
wissen ich habe mit Zeff noch nie was gemacht
kein Plan davon
und wir müssen die Quelle wieder löschen
ok das ging jetzt doch schneller als gedacht
Unuse Storage
Remove
jetzt brauche ich aber eigentlich auch
Replication gar nicht mehr
jetzt sollte das ja alles automatisch
mit dem Storage
funktionieren jetzt kann ich mir das eigentlich sparen
ja
brauche ich keine
Add ne ist eigentlich
ziemlich unsinnig
ok
und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage
also
Replication macht ja
keinen Sinn mehr an der Stelle
wir haben ja quasi gemeinsam uns
Netzwerk Storage
wo das Ding drauf liegt
ich meine es kann durchaus sein dass das immer noch nicht
funktioniert
starten
Console
ah ok
vm ist fast wieder oben
ok vm ist da
jetzt migraten
gucken wir uns doch mal an ob das jetzt irgendwie länger
ausfällt oder so
Ping
ein Ping ist eigentlich ein blödes Ding
weil das hängt dann manchmal einfach
bis es halt dann wieder eine Antwort bekommt
also es könnte durchaus sein dass neue Requests
tatsächlich fehlschlagen
Migrate
na das ging jetzt mal zackig oder
das war komplett
ohne irgendwelche Downtime die Migration
von einem Node zum anderen
da kannst du dich nicht beschweren
das hat mal kurz eine Millisekunde gezuckt
das ist gut
das war
gut
das hat jetzt mal eine Millisekunde gezuckt und dann war gut
das ist nice
1,63 Millisekunden Hänger
wo stand das
hier
hier ne hier stand kurz
ne oder stand das hier irgendwie beim
Migrieren oder wo habt ihr das
gesehen
oder habt ihr das ausgerechnet jetzt
Quick Maps
ok
und jetzt ist die Frage
wenn ich den
Node ausschalte
muss ich vorher noch was einschalten
dass der automatisch migratet
oder irgendwas noch einschalten
Option
HA
na Replication wirds ja nicht sein
Datacenter
HA
ah
ok
Max Restarts, Max Relocate
Keck machen wir nicht
was das verstehe ich nicht was das mir genau
sagen soll
wahrscheinlich wie oft es neu umverteilt
werden darf um irgendwie eine bessere
Cluster Performance zu gewährleisten
oder sowas
ja dann
probieren wir das doch mal aus
gucken was jetzt passiert
ich bin ja mal gespannt
Zack
Power
Off
Bam
ok Vm hängt
das hätte ich jetzt auch nicht anders gerechnet
damit gerechnet
muss ich jetzt erstmal mitbekommen
ist auch nicht Instant
jetzt müsste er aber
vielleicht sollte ich auch mal auf den anderen Node jetzt drauf
weil
den gibts ja gar nicht mehr
ok
ne
das scheint immer noch nicht zu funktionieren
oder braucht er einfach noch
braucht er noch
es erscheint auch im Log
nichts von wegen Serverdown oder sowas
HA ohne Anleitung
ja ich hab keinen Plan davon
was hier überhaupt passiert
wahrscheinlich ist es nicht ganz richtig was ich hier gemacht habe
oder?
ah der weiß gar nicht wohin er die
migraten soll
der weiß glaube ich gar nicht wohin er die migraten soll
ok
kann ich so migraten?
aber das ist ja doof dass das nicht geht
ich mein ich hab jetzt schon ein shared storage
und alles
ich brauch wirklich noch ein dritten
selbst zum ausprobieren
das kann ich heute nicht mehr machen
dann installier ich morgen
ein dritten
wieso ist das doch genau das was im Titel steht
ok
das funktioniert nicht
das mach ich morgen Leute
ich find das wirklich nicht schlecht
bis jetzt
und ich bin gespannt
ob ich das hinkriege
das machen wir morgen
ich glaube wir installieren morgen noch ein dritten Node
right now it takes about
200... ja das ist aber schon rum
und selbst das hier
von Hand funktioniert ja nicht
aber wisst ihr was ich merkwürdig
finde?
dass
es keine Cluster IP
gibt für den Webservice
das ist doch irgendwie ein bisschen komisch oder?
dass der Webservice
immer noch Node based ist
wir schalten das andere Ding
mal wieder ein
ja aber das ist doch egal wir müssen nichts extra
laufen lassen wir machen einfach morgen noch
ein dritten Node und gut ist
du kannst dem zweiten
Node einfach eine Stimme mehr
geben
ja wo?
Proxmox Web Interface
Cluster IP
Under
Data Center Cluster
ne anscheinend geht das Web Interface nicht
das ist aber doof
so die Form ist wieder da
alles gut
hat funktioniert
aber
dass man das Web Interface nicht im Cluster
laufen kann ist natürlich doof
da hätte ich jetzt eigentlich fest mit gerechnet
dass es irgendwie sowas gibt
ich mein
vielleicht
geht das auch noch mit einem dritten Node
oder aber
jetzt kommt Trick 17
wir könnten eine
HA verfügbare VM erstellen
die
proxyd
durch die Brust ins Auge oder
wie gesagt aber
ich baue morgen eh einen dritten Node dabei
und gut ist
das ist schon in Ordnung
ich finde das eigentlich gar nicht schlecht
dann sieht man auch so ob es direkt out of the box funktioniert
so wie es gedacht ist
also ich mein für das Web Interface könnte man das echt so machen
man würde eine VM installieren
die VM
wenn das mit dem automatisch migrieren funktioniert
und dann wäre eine VM
mit dem Proxy und der Proxy
proxied halt dann auf die drei
Backends hier
das würde funktionieren
das ist zwar ein bisschen Lösung durch die Brust ins Auge
aber das sollte gehen
und die sollte dann auch umschwenken
ok
das machen wir
dann wir machen morgen weiter
ich finde das Thema sehr spannend
aber heute kann ich nicht mehr machen
weil ich muss 22 Uhr Bett geh
und dann muss ich morgen früh wieder arbeiten gehen
zu Hause ein Cluster brauche ich nicht
rein zum testen
hat keinen tieferen Sinn
ich habe eh nur
einen Node daheim
wo ich das drauf laufen lasse
also insofern
nehmen wir halt einen Raspberry Pi
warum?
warum soll ich mit dem Raspberry Pi anfangen
ok was ist das hier
4 Minuten das gucken wir uns jetzt noch an
PHP will make you poor
Stack Overflow Results
die haben wir uns doch schon angeguckt
it is June 21st, 2023
ich wollte mal nur kurz die Musik ausmachen
jawohl
exzellent
das haben wir uns auch schon angeguckt
RAS ist wieder sehr beliebt
Dart
wer benutzt auch schon Dart
mir fällt nur Flutter ein
und warum die ausgerechnet
mit diesem Müll anfangen mussten
dass es Dart based ist, verstehe ich trotzdem nicht
hätten sie sich einfach Javascript nehmen können
dann hätte man wenigstens das große Ökosystem gehabt
oder meinetwegen Go
dann wäre es Google intern geblieben
warum muss Flutter
auf Dart basieren
sehe ich auch so
CSS, HTML
ist einfach die beste Programmiersprache
Ruby kann ich sogar irgendwie verstehen
das liegt daran
weil es noch ganz viele
Ruby Legacy
Web Services gibt
und es gibt nicht mehr viele
Ruby Entwickler
Ruby
Ruby ist richtig gut
was du hier anschaust ist ein neuer Chart
auf dem Survey
der das geliebte und verdächtige Chart
auf den vorherigen Stack Overflow Surveys verwendet
wenn du einen roten Punkt links hast
bedeutet das, dass die Sprache von Menschen
die es benutzen
wenn du einen blauen Punkt links hast
bedeutet das, dass es von Menschen
die es nicht benutzt
ist
RAS wird halt kaum nachgefragt
aber hier guck mal
das ist tatsächlich ganz gut
halbwegs halbwegs gescheit gesucht
und die Leute mögen es
wirklich ein ganz guter Spot für eine Sprache
das wundert mich nicht
machen sie das ja
siehst du
Leute wir wussten schon immer
das Ding ist halt
du kannst es nicht wirklich vergleichen
das ist halt schon ein bisschen fies
insofern Hetzner kann halt von Features
absolut nicht mithalten von AWS
aber dafür was Hetzner anbietet
ich meine
es sind ja eigentlich nur VMs
Hetzner Clouds sind VMs und Managed Load Balancer
ich glaube es waren sogar
Nginx Kisten unten drunter
das war es, also die haben weder Managed Datenbank
noch irgendwie
wie geahnt auch immer
anderen Cloud Services
die AWS oder Google oder Azure
oder was auch immer anbietet
dafür das was sie haben und zwar VMs
hat finde ich das beste Web Interface
von allen Hostern
wo findet man den Graph eigentlich
hier
Stack Overflow
hier ist der ganze Camp hier drinnen
Ja
die haben halt
die Zeiten verschlafen
und die haben ihr Free Tier eingestellt
selbst schuld
Svelte ist beliebt
Das ist nicht Elektron?
Elektron mit Native Webview?
Wundert nicht
Ja
aber jetzt auch nicht so einen großen Unterschied
fällt mir bei der Gelegenheit übrigens
gerade ein, ich wollte ja auch nochmal einen NeoVim Stream machen
demnächst
Ja
so muss es auch sein
es macht überhaupt gar keinen Sinn
dass die Leute ins Büro kommen sollen
in so einem Technik Job
Ja
also bei mir ist es aktuell
ich gehöre zu den oberen Prozent
ich bin einmal die Woche im Büro
und den Rest bin ich Remote am Start
weil ich ja insgesamt eh nur 4 Tage die Woche am Start bin
Alles klar jetzt wissen wir Bescheid
PHP
eh ehrlich gesagt finde ich es gar nicht schlecht
weil wir haben letztens ein bisschen PHP
ausprobiert wieder und das hat mich echt
abgefuckt
wir sehen uns morgen
morgen geht es weiter Proxmox Cluster
bis dann macht es gut
Achso, wen hosten wir?
Wie hieß dieser C++ Channel?
Leute C++
ich hoste jetzt den C++ Channel
wartet mal
ich habe es mir jetzt überhaupt nicht angeguckt
eh
irgendjemand
hatte doch hier C++
was Volk?
ne
Twitch
C++
hier, machen die noch C++?
der Weg jemanden anzuschreiben
mit einem untergeordneten Charakter
die Kataster
was ist das?
eine Information
das ist nicht modernes C++
Programming
das ist noch abgedrehteres Zeug
oh ne ne ne
damit quäle ich euch jetzt nicht Leute
damit quäle ich euch jetzt nicht
following
live
die F-Sharp Conference
oh ne
der Sprecher ist aber auch
auf Twitch manchmal
ok keine Ahnung
wir sehen uns, macht es gut, bis dann
CIO